welcome everybody and welcome to West
area plumbing my name is Marc card you
know I'm chairing the meeting this
evening
first a bit of housekeeping there are no
fire alarm scheduled this evening so if
you do hear one making way out in an
orderly fashion to the car park down by
the side of the windmill pub please
please note this is a planning meeting
with public participation not a public
meeting therefore only persons
registered to speak will be allowed to
do so during the evening this is being
webcast if you don't wish to be seen in
the world big board World Wide Web then
please don't officer know the
appropriate time right um for our
speakers this evening some tips on the
microphone you don't need to get too
close to it otherwise it becomes
distorted so if you just a little isms
way and speak clearly everything should
be fine right the sequence even through
each application is as follows I will
introduce the item supported by the case
officer who offers a description town
and parish councillors are allowed to
speak for up to three minutes
remember the public objecting allowed to
speak for up to three minutes the
applicant will be allowed to speak for a
commercial time up to three or six
minutes please note that on the first
item
educate way we've doubled the time on
those I will give a 30-second warning
before times up ward members will then
be able to speak for up to five minutes
at all stages the members of the
committee are able to ask questions
following presentation we will then move
to question the case officer on
technical issues following that debate
and then into the vote right this is all
inside your agendas would you mind
please turn your phones either to off or
to silent for the duration of the
meeting please thank you there is an
update sheet on the chairs around for
any late-breaking news on the items
before us this evening right I'll now
ask the officers to introduce themselves
starting from my right
Caroline Nash committee administrator
Ross chambers legal services
I'm Richard Gardner I'm the planning
manager my role is as an impartial
advisor to the committee and to help
so any questions that arise I'm bound by
the code of Professional Conduct of the
Royal Town Planning Institute during the
meeting or may be asked to comment on
points raised seek clarifications and
advise on planning practice to ensure
that the decision made by committee is
sound committee members are not bound by
the case officers recommendation or by
oral advice Alex Cosmo a Senior Planner
vensim watch accounts council highways
Stephen Hawley
worcestershire County Council highways
thank you everybody
right apologies for absence thank you
very much disclosures of interest
members are there any disclosures you
wish to raise council carriage
I'm the war member for the British
gateway application which is for and the
25 aerials to Road application which is
number six and I've objected to both so
I'll be standing down and speaking Thank
You chairman and I have received an
overwhelming amount of documentation on
reddit gateway I believe although the
councillors have as well I've also had
an independent email in relation to that
my mind is still open and I will make my
decision based on YC thank you I agree
we've all heard also for clarity I
received an email today for all the
second item kissing country gate as well
I think a number of members have seen
that too okay thank you
minutes of meeting have members had an
opportunity to look at the minutes and
they were happy for me to sign it after
the meeting okay thank you
well in that case then we may as well
move straight into the the first item on
the agenda this is application 17-0 1 8
4 7/8 reddish gateway this has been
before us before and was deferred for
further information the presenting
officer is Alice Kozma to yours Thank
You chairman the application site as
identified by the black dots in the
center of the plan is local
on the edge of the built-up area of
Redditch the site as outlined in red is
allocated for employment development and
the policies red one and red two of the
core strategy the application site falls
within the jurisdictions have strapped
on Aven District Council read each
District Council and Bromsgrove District
Council
three identical applications have been
submitted to each authoritative edit and
Bromsgrove have both received a
resolution to grant by their respective
planning committees this hybrid planning
application seeks outlined consent with
matters of appearance landscaping layout
scale and details of internal
circulation routes reserved for the
development on a phased basis of 32
hectares of employment land for business
and industrial uses and full planning
permission for the phase 1 ground
engineering works and primary means of
access to the site from the Coventry
highway the application was heard at
Planning Committee on the 6th of
December 2017 and was deferred on the
basis of the need for guidance to be
provided on where tool buildings would
be located within the southern
development parcel in light of their
impacts on the dwellings of farm or lane
and on the basis of insufficient
information having been provided on
traffic management with specific regard
to the HCV routing strategy and the
amount of the bond requested at 200,000
pounds an amended parameters plan as
shown on the slide has been submitted in
response to the committee's concerns
regarding the impact of the development
on dwellings are far more Lane the
parameters plans submitted shows various
employment zones detailing maximum
building heights the heights in the
north and development parcel remain as
previously proposed however the southern
development parcel has been amended so
here i've zoomed in on the amended
parameters plan to show the relationship
between the southern development zone
and dwellings are far more lane at a
closer scale the amended parameters plan
moves the southern development parcel
further away from the western boundary
of the site and a hatched area to a
width of 15 metres has been incorporated
along the entire western boundary
buildings within this hatched area would
not exceed 15 metres in height the 21
meter height shown in the rest of the
southern development parcel would remain
as pre
we proposed as is clear from the plan
residential dwellings on far more lane
would be located in excess of 68 metres
from the development parcel beyond a
width of perimeter landscaping this
photo is taken from the public footpath
which runs adjacent to far more Lane and
the western boundary of the site to
assist members in assessing the
relationship of the site with the
dwellings are far more lane the distance
between this footpath and the visible
dwelling on Halle Berry close which can
be seen in the photo equates to
approximately 30 metres the proposed
development zone would be another 38
metres to the right of this photo beyond
to a belt of perimeter landscaping in
excess of 20 metres in width and an
internal access road committee also
deferred the application on the basis of
traffic management and the amount for
the 200 thousand pound bond our highways
briefing notes has been provided by the
applicant this outlines the modelling
undertaken and provides additional
information on how the HTV routing
strategy would work in practice
identifying specific routes for HCBS to
avoid routes through steadily as well as
ongoing monitoring and penalties for
non-compliance as shown in tables on
page 47 of your agenda a relatively
small proportion of page TV traffic
would choose to route south along the a
435 and this is without the mitigation
to be secured through conditions and the
legal agreement
Juuso members are aware the plans photos
and videos shown in the previous
presentation are available if members
wish to see them since the report and
update sheet went to print highways
england has confirmed that the amended
parameters plan and highways briefing
notes submitted since the defer or a
committee on the 6th of December has no
implications to their previous position
of no objection in conclusion as
identified on page 74 of your agenda
limited harm arises as a result of this
development however the proposal gives
rise to significant benefits through its
status as an allocated site for
employment purposes chairman the
recommendation is to approve the
application in accordance with the
recommendation detailed in the update
sheet thank you thank you guys
our first speaker this evening given
we've got at least two I think maybe
three new members on the committee
you haven't had the benefit of those
site plans and the videos is it worth us
having a look at those now if they're
available please sorry I've also got a
lot of backup slides here which weren't
in the previous presentation so I'll
just pick out those ones which were
previously shown so here we've got the
illustrative master plan which has been
provided it is illustrative so it
doesn't show how the development will
necessarily come forward if it gives
members an idea of how it could come
forward in any subsequent reserve matter
submissions this photo is taken from the
commentary highway so you've got the
Northern Development parcel on the
left-hand side of the site of the photo
the southern development parcel on the
right-hand side of the photo so this is
where the new access Junction would be
located and this plan shows the plans
for the access junction which is a
signalized junction the full element
includes engineering works and these can
be seen here so it would involve the
first development plateau to allow for
the access and the first unit and
involve some minor grading of the site
but it wouldn't result in any additional
land coming off or off the the
development site in terms of the the
videos I've got a couple of videos which
members will be able to view so if you
could just take note of where I was
stood in the videos you can see this one
here video one and this one here video
two and I'll just show you those so this
is stirred adjacent to the western
boundary panning around the southern
development parcel so you can see that a
4:35 in the distance over here
panning around to the north of the site
this shows the existing perimeter
landscaping which would be bolstered
round to the public footpath and the
dwelling was on long hope clothes which
are located to the south of the
development site and video to I'm stood
in the northern parcel panning around
toward the location here of Gorka Hall
in the distance and the woodland and
then the industrial units which are an
existence on the western boundary of the
Northern Development site planning round
to the Coventry highway which you can
just see there and then this final slide
is the other one which was shown at
previous presentation and just shows the
locations of listed buildings thank you
excellent thank you very much indeed
right our first speaker then is a cancer
or sorry Steve and Cally's causa castle
yes thank you very much indeed Casa from
Micawber green posh
yes yes I think so
thank you have three minutes in your own
time yes press the button at the bottom
that's it fantastic thank you thank you
well I'd like to go first 2 to 8 article
2 HC least the briefing note and it's an
extent the request about how I seemed to
the upper right in four to jump through
was address assist use an existing
resume model maintained by a Qi this was
identified that a proposed development
traffic slightly increases the to the
i-435
approach to however he has confirmed the
government funding has been allocated to
provide a large-scale improvement scheme
to this Junction well we were promised
to study bypass so I don't think that's
anything to go by a taught sound that
they're going to give us money for Road
three to the development will generate
fifty three and nine to HDTV movements
during the morning and evening peak
hours respectively the peak as I defined
as eight or nine and five to six the
distribution of these ATVs you've shown
in figures two and three and equate to a
maximum of eight h.d these routing to
allocation to the set of Redditch so
that means we're only going together
eight extra values going through mapable
degree and steadily which is ridiculous
it's not something that will not affect
the up this use of the report the level
of HCV traffic is not significant and
will not affect the operations of the
junctions to the south of the site
including Studley because if all these
nobody mentions an apple butter green
where the actual building is going
nobody mentions that in any of these
that rivet is not significant and will
that affects the operation of the
junction to the south of the site
including Studley when compared to the
existing normal of HGVs well it's just
rubbish three four throughout the
scoping discussions were lecture County
Council expressed concern regarding the
potential impact of the development
traffic in studly Welsh council
therefore commissioned a Vectis micro
Susan to understate the sense
Trivedi tests of the predicted
development traffic used in the study
area panics if a microstimulation model
to provide a robust test the money has
assumed that 50% of the total HCV
movement generated by the development
would release ludley a significant ovis
overestimated their level is traffic
that would route through Studley data
get that said that's rubbish impactions
proposed development overall the what
you can see CAD modeling exercise
conclude that even with a significant
over estimation of traffic development
still not to have any impacts upon the
efficient operation and the highways
network within Studley hence there is no
justification for capacity improvements
berkshire county council so nothing's
going to be done anywhere at all
3:7 is published October transduce study
was undertaken by Atkins and comprised
HCV origin and destination surveys and
only a 4 35 km 40 and Junction 3 that
was just one day of one year judge 3 8
10 phase 1 he was relating to study well
as follows over a typical 24-hour period
most ATVs traveling within the study
area had a local purpose serving the
local economies of read each study and
also so digitally though trips journeys
made along the entire length of the
i-435
without stopping within the local area
at Kent you're only Sims so 7 not even
100 go all the way through all the other
stuff
93 buddy stop the other 700 go all the
way through which I think you drive do
you have to stop you there you had your
three minutes unfortunately however yes
you have thank you could collect could I
just say one more thing please very
briefly right very briefly we are rate
payers of Stratford district this is our
District Council the multimillionaires
are gonna walk away millions of power
from this project will leave us with the
problems as as a patient of these care
so I'll just close I hope you vote
against it
because if it goes to appeal the win
anyway but at least you'll shown you
with the people
right were there any questions that you
wanted to answer the counselor no okay
thank you very much
right we do have now a number of
speakers one two three four or five and
I believe you've all allocated your
tongues of accordingly and what I'm
going to suggest members is after each
presentation we'll just have a short
question and answer of the speaker that
excuse me so yes we'll do that right the
first speaker then is mr. Christopher
Eden and I believe mr. Len quickly is
reading better quickly I apologize I
couldn't get your oh yeah so if you'd
like to come to the microphone and then
read out your statement thank you do you
know how your timings incidentally one
minute 20 seconds okay thank you
Zonk that's what just checking your
obvious you can hear me okay good
sorry no indeed well I thank you very
much for that advance thank you
this development will bring increased
pollution with 1600 sorry 1600 car
spaces and 80 lorry lorry Bay's this is
a very large increase in traffic much of
which will use the access road currently
proposed to run within 60 metres or so
of Winnie rates green housing with the
traffic increase there will be an
increase in pollution in the area the
lorries will be predominantly diesel as
well many of the cars diesel is
well-known as a pollutant and raises
health concerns research published in
January 17 by Liberty University Center
for cardiovascular science found the
diesel exhaust fumes are deadly emitting
ten times more pollutants than petrol
engines diesel pollutants include fine
particles shown to cause amongst many
problems including respiratory and
asthma symptoms cardio pulmonary
mobility
long than other cancers strokes heart
disease Parkinson's disease excuse me
and preeclampsia leading to smaller
and/or primped premature babies and
summons and deaths the statistics about
diesels are not crystal clear this
development will visit these health
problems on redditch and in particular
Winget greenland mapable green and
studly one minute 20 thank you I just
say then the amendments before you do
nothing to prevent the increased
pollution you should rethink your
decision to approve such a scheme
particularly for the Southside thank you
Jeff thank you very much members there
any questions you'd like to ask okay
thank you very much
right our next speaker is maureen berry
governor of Malibu green primary school
my main concerns relate to the children
as moisture highways and central
government are well aware there is
already significant issues relating to
the a 435 in the a four one eight nine
through macabre green work is due to
start or Excel highways on with Marisha
highways on the 19th of February on the
a four one eight nine to try and
alleviate the problems of traffic
saturation and speed that this that they
is caused by the may be the adverse
traffic in the last twelve months
the traffic has contributed to incidents
involving three young children and their
families trying to do a safer journey to
school
wise your highways representatives have
made comment at the last meeting that
this was an ongoing problem and
acknowledge the ongoing issue why then
is it deemed necessary to excessive
eight the problem by bringing more
vehicles into the area as the ready GC
Gateway project would inevitably do no
mention in the amendments has been made
to the routing of cars which are as
dangerous to little children as any
other vehicle cars do not call cars do
not only cause one minute thank you
cars do not only cause congestion but
also diesel cars cause significant
pollution and as the school is near the
a 435 Institute situated on the a4 189
I'm unable to find in the amendment any
contingency relating to air pollution
and volume of general traffic I
therefore ask you to consider protecting
our next generation and not putting
their lives more at risk thank you very
much thank you sorry
now though we haven't done the pollution
test at school we've been doing surveys
on traffic by high winds have been doing
surveys on traffic for us the next stage
I believe is we are looking to look into
the pollution aspects because obviously
this is getting drastically worse
especially around that area
thank you any other questions smells No
thank you very much I believe now we
have council right do you have a set
time counselor yes thank you
based on the modeling exercise that
Warwickshire our authority claims
chocolate would not have a detrimental
impact on steadily and yet the report in
front of you recognizes the need for
heavy good rooting strategy to prevent
vehicles traveling down the 8th or 3 5
so the potential is recognized it is
there that this could happen making it
very difficult for members to accept
that for ATVs we'll just go through
study at D time especially as the
analyst analysis in the report is
questionable and has come before the
committee as a briefing note the 500
contributions the mitigation to cover
the fifth verse 15 years that's all
they're offering but then we have to
fall back on policing by planning
condition and we know what's happened in
the past when that happens it is
unreliable especially so far in the
future they need to be more secure
details brought to this committee that
covers the long term potential and
prospect for this development and by
that I don't mean I mean generations I
don't mean 15 years it's going to
develop going to take to develop this
project so please consider the long term
future and possibly refuse at this time
and ask for better than analysis that
may be been given in report okay thank
you captain
any questions on
Council cattle ask about the long term
no doubt it
I can pray but I don't think it'll do
any good okay thank you very much casa
so general it's generations we have to
consider thank you
our next speaker is counselor paul
Swansboro we only accept them up to the
day day before the okay okay thank you
well firstly can I say thank you for
give me the time to speak this evening
here in stratford-upon-avon up for and
on behalf of the residents of we eighth
ward in Redditch I wish to object to the
proposals located within the southern
development parcel for the following
material considerations one transport
infrastructure there is no consideration
in the transport assessment to cater for
the potential increase in hgv overnight
parking in the locality all of the
labels located on the a 435 between
Reddick and Junction 3 of the m42 are
currently at capacity an independent
review commissioned by Bromsgrove
district council also raises huge
concerns over the methodology used to
calculate the transport modeling I
therefore ask how a site claiming to
create two and a half thousand jobs
would only generate three hundred and
thirty eight vehicles arriving at a.m.
times to air quality no information on
the impact of the proposed development
with regard to air quality in
neighboring reddish district is present
in the application current co2 emissions
per 1000 of the population in the
locality are the second highest in
Worcestershire
three sustainability the reddit Borough
Council employment land review 2014 and
it's updates do not take into account
the current surplus of commercial
properties in the new town estimated to
be 500,000 square feet or velocity 42 a
brownfield project that is currently
under construction that will provide a
further three hundred and thirty
thousand square feet of b1 b2 and b8
type units sorry we are running out of
time this is very important the
application is therefore not sustainable
in its current form and as such
revisions need to be written
need to reflect the current local
economic conditions and the needs of the
community finally land usage read each
currently has a significantly more
urgent need for affordable housing over
employment land and therefore the Winnie
eights green triangle is considerably
more suitable site to expand an existing
residential area this is fully in line
with the national planning policy
framework that clearly states that we
should ensure that sufficient land is
made available in the right places at
the right time to support growth and
innovation right counsel Beaman that's
right sorry I apologize didn't you
mentioned a fuller housing being more
appropriate in this area am i right in
thinking that this has been allocated in
the reddit core strategy for its current
use I misunderstood that it local plan
for which refers to the employment land
review which is what I mentioned in
terms of sustainability it has been
allocated as employment land however I
as a counselor representing my residents
in Redditch I never supported the local
plan form because I didn't think that
land was appropriately for employment if
we if there were to be a proposal to go
in a for for housing it would be against
your your
councils core strategy as well as ours
which not party but it forms part of the
local plan what I'm saying to you in my
sustainability section I spoke to is one
of the documents that supports local
plan for is the employment land review
that does not take into consideration
the surplus today and the fact that we
have another development currently
underway that would provide three
hundred thousand square feet it's out of
date is now a date document it needs a
date and it cannot be used as evidence
to sell this project thank you no more
questions
thank you thank you hmm council Beeman
you have three seconds sorry Jared as
always it's a pleasure to be here Thank
You members this out this application
hopefully have a massive impact on sadly
other villages on the a 435 unless it's
considered as a wider scheme and
infrastructure is put in place work she
wrote Safety's team who raised concerns
on the junction the i-435 402 three and
that's for amelioration works however
even they get it wrong they put it as a
60 monorail it's a 70 mile an hour limit
or dual code writer and there are
national speed limit is 70 not sixty
that needs to be considered
Stratford District Council's
environmental health have concerns about
the advisory nature of the HPV routine
strategy the lots of other little bits
and pieces the final comment I think
planning committees have always been
instructed that if they need to put
conditions on an application to make it
acceptable those conditions must be
reasonable and enforceable we do not
think the conditions that are put on
this are reasonable they will not work
and SDC and WCC do not have the
resources to enforce those conditions
and therefore this application cannot be
permitted thank you I think this
question this question might be welcome
for you you talked about the conditions
that can't be enforced can you explain
to me which
can't be and why I think it's it the
routing strategy they they offer some
solutions from finding drivers having
possibly trackers in the cabs we are
talking about distribution warehouses
surly people come from all over Europe
from all over the world to deliver to
their to say that they are going to get
fined or told that they can't come that
way to me is a complete nonsense and I
do not see how this cancel or County
Council can actually enforce that it's
impossible which will go wherever they
seem fit and and that is the biggest
problem here many of the questions for
members I think I picked up the the
theme obviously is transport and this
will be picked up with the questions
later on as I leave it in your capable
hands to thank your engine team right
thank you everybody next speakers is Rob
box because it Rob Wells David Brown and
Alex Morgan
thank you and you have 9 minutes a year
in time thank you
Thank You chairman slat okay thank you
for providing us with the opportunity to
speak in support of proposals as you
said before I start we have two of the
two options here who can help answer any
questions that you might have once we
finished don't get too close to the
waters at your meeting on 6th of
December you deferred consideration of
the application for the following
reasons
more information on traffic management
to particular relation to HTV more
information on the proposed bond and
clarifications on where taller buildings
may be located within the development
following your decision the applicant
has considered your comments and as you
have heard has submitted additional
information to you providing an
explanation of the highway proposals for
the development the information that has
been provided and assessed as part of
the planning application has been agreed
by two hiring authorities highways
England and high-risk consultants on
behalf of Bromsgrove Council as being
robust
with specific regard to the HTV
movements the analysis confirmed that
even without any proposed mitigation the
traffic associated with the development
is within acceptable limits
notwithstanding this the applicant has
agreed to measures over and above those
necessary for the development to provide
an additional benefit this is in the
form of the HTV routing plan the route
of which has been submitted through the
transport assessment which was submitted
with the application and will result in
HTV for the development not rooting
through not reaching South Sumatra green
or steadily unless for example they have
deliveries to make the applicant is
funding the implementation running and
monitoring of the plan including
reporting to the Highways authorities
the 200,000 pounds bond that is being
provided is to pay for any additional
unforeseen measures that might be
required as part and parcel of the
implementation of the route proposals
for example making additional changes to
traffic regulations or additional
signage for hi Reza thora tees are only
able to request contributions where they
are justified the amount of the bond has
been determined by the hiring
authorities again I would reiterate that
application provision has been fully
assessed by the two high res authorities
bronze Coast consultants and high res
England the applicant is therefore fully
responded to the requests of the highway
regulatory authorities in who in their
responses to you have advised that the
proposals are acceptable on highways
grounds the note that we submitted also
confirms that there are significant
transport and high risk costs associated
with development on which the
development is bearing this includes all
the highways works associated with
creating the new signalized Junction and
off-site works including changes to the
southbound a 435 slip these works which
having a cost of approximately 3 million
pounds have been agreed with the
Highways authorities separately your
committee commented on proposed height
of the buildings were their closest to
some of the houses at windows green as
you're aware the application previously
agreed to amend the parameters plan to
remove the southern field from the
development area thereby providing
additional separation between the houses
on along Hope close on the development
all in consideration of your comments
and as you have heard the applicant is
introduced to further hike restriction
of buildings in the development zone
parallel to farm or lane this is
introduces the zone within which
building Heights will not exceed 15
metres the applicant has therefore shown
willingness to amend proposals to
reflect the concerns of your committee
with the updated information on the
amended plans in front of you the
applicant considers that they have
addressed your concerns I'd also had to
focus briefly again on the benefits of
the development it's identified as one
of the four game-changer sites for us to
share and it's just supported by either
local enterprise partnerships
waterschei County Council and is
included in the Deaf invest in Britain
portfolio through the Midlands enging
which is promoting sites internationally
it helps to address the employment land
requirements for Redditch as endorsed by
two planning inspectors and as you have
recently just questioned or the previous
speaker it is an allocation within three
local plans they will create an estate
Inman estimated minimum of 2,000 jobs
and represents a development investment
100
million pounds it would also help
address localized flood issues improved
local watercourses your officers have
endorsed additional information provided
and the proposed changed the parameters
plan and lastly for having recommended
to you that the application be approved
the application the applicants re
therefore trust that you will now be
able to do operation as a ready to
compromise both councils have already
done thank you thank you and picking up
on a few of the points that have been
raised very councillor obviously the
traffic management element of this is is
there's very very importance of
everybody around this area and also the
to a Leominster is a management of that
plan the implementation of that plan and
the longevity of it as well because
obviously things change different
clients and different conditions change
on that site or will do over time so can
you just reiterate please for me the how
the plan is actually physically going to
work with your clients whoever they may
be and implementing it with them and
ensuring that they adhere to that
particular plan and over what period of
time are you expecting this to work I
think the first point to make is that
HDV movements throughout the country
it's not a unique experience or concern
for development sites and occupiers are
becoming more and more used to having to
deal with these issues and ensuring that
their drivers drive on recognized routes
and don't cut through you know from that
go off trunk roads or motorways even
when there's there's traffic problems so
we are confident that occupiers who come
to this site will sign up and want to
manage their drivers to ensure that
they're not going to route south down
through mapable green and studly we've
understood that this has been an issue
from day one when these sites got
allocated
and we've worked hard with the Highways
authorities to ensure and persuade them
that we can enforce it at the site we
would use modern technologies we're
proposing to use number plate
recognition and also we're occupiers
have trackers in their cabs we will use
that information as well we've run this
past a couple of major occupiers already
just to get their view on it and they
don't have concerns they understand that
there are these sort of problems and
they are just encountering these you
know in all parts of the country you
know it's far more so in the southeast
of the country where there's more
congestion and can I just add also there
for you in terms of the condition the
development will have to be carried out
in accordance with the conditions that
are imposed upon the plan a question
that runs with the Planning Commission
so unless and until any application is
made to you to vary any such condition
then the developer will have to be in
accordance with the routing management
plan and the implementation plan that's
agreed through this okay so the question
that council cargle I was quite if
you're the one I was going to ask I'm
not entirely convinced this briefing
notes giving me any more information you
didn't give me verbally last time but
just for clarity you've talked about
ANPR and here it says alternative
technology I assume that's trackers is
there anything else if not can you
insist on trackers going in all the
vehicles going to it from the site how
are you gonna deal with European
visitors people from outside of our own
country and you've just talked about a
very are you suggesting that there might
be a very to come or is that just just
let me do with the last point first no
we're not suggesting there's any
proposals to make the application to
variation but hosted
is that if you apply a condition to the
planet question it runs with that
development I'm well aware of that so
those the questions I've already put and
also in terms of the in the enforcement
of this who's responsible for that
you've got are you guys going to have a
management team that enforce it and that
feeds into our system so that we
understand what's going on I mean the
proposals we've looked at at the moment
are having a camera on the entrance to
any of the new units at the Business
Park that would also be cameras we've
had discs talking to the Highways
authorities installing cameras on the a
for 3-5 through Studley so we will be
able to recognize number plates
immediately on exit or entrance to the
development and they will be tracked
through cameras on the eighth floor
three scythe
so immediately with the software that's
available now it will pop up if there's
an issue with a particular vehicle going
in the wrong direction and we will use
that through the management company or
the management company that it's going
to be established for this high quality
business part and that will be reported
directly to the Highways authorities if
that's the case it'll be part of their
responsibility to manage that scheme
sort of answers a little bit trackers
can you insist I don't think that
tracker
if trackers are available to all
operators at the moment but you can't
except I could foresee that coming but
you know there's some smaller businesses
that won't have that so I think the
number plate recognition at the moment
is the right technology to you I think
that in conjunction with trackers would
young West our European visitors so if
you've got a NPR or cameras tracking
people coming in they come in once maybe
twice they have how you're going to make
sure they go in the right direction
coming to the site how how they going to
know I think the occupiers wreck
that they need to manage their suppliers
and you know are you saying are you
saying that drivers will only come once
or twice and that's it I mean I think
they were if they were driving over here
there'd be regular visitors
so therefore if they're if they're up
for losing their jobs or not being able
to drive a particular route they'll take
note of the enforcement that we're
putting forward document it talks about
a disciplinary system for breaches who
is responsible for issuing that
discipline the occupier will look to the
management company to manage this
because they'll be independent from the
occupier we wouldn't want to rely on the
occupier I do so you're saying the
management company is going to have the
ability to issue disciplinary warning to
lorry drivers attached to a particular
Co they'll serve the occupier who will
then serve the driver and have to be
audited and as promised pan pass or the
lip of the scheme the occupiers have to
sign up to these provisions council
bonds you know I've heard all about I
was the one that proposed the first
payment and that's what we're here again
I was fully supported you haven't
addressed anything about the environment
in the perspective we've had through
spook is now talking about the pollution
in your management company is there
anything councillors palm part of the
application there was information
submitted in the environmental statement
regarding air quality and potential
impacts from both construction and
operational aspects of the development
and that includes taking account of
traffic traffic Commission's foster
share regulatory authorities were happy
with the information I'm submitting as
was the response from the equipment's at
Stratford subjects the conditions that
are being proposed to you
castle Vaudrey Thank You chair see
number plate recognition isn't new it is
though a development you can point us to
where such a provision of auditing
traffic flows is established is working
and a similar management company set up
is actually able to effectively enforce
it cific examples here this evening but
I'm sure that's information we can
provide
there are definitely schemes up and
running elsewhere in the country using
this technology I'm sorry sorry the use
of routing management plans is it's an
unusual position I mean there is the
direct development in Northamptonshire
on the boundaries of Hampton and on the
m1 that has that as a routing hydrant
system most major for example most major
residential schemes the operate
management routing management plans for
the construction vehicles to to stick to
so the principle of using routing margin
plans is not something that's new
councillor Jones no I think the issue is
it's the enforceability because my
concern so I just want to ask about this
disciplinary system because if this
estate management company say we've got
a third offense and management company's
opinion his driver should be suspended
because they're persistent breaches so
you tell occupier whichever employer
this is right they need to get rid of
their driver
do they have to what we're agreeing
through planning otherwise they'll be
you know we can take enforcement through
through the planning I think the key
point is really that you know we
recognize that concerns
raising in terms of how's it including
how is it going to be fully implemented
and what's the sanction on the on
occupiers so we have to have the
occupiers that sign up to the system so
they are fully aware of what those
issues are they will have to then feed
that down to their drivers and so that
the drivers are fully aware of the
implications
so the aim through the fact through the
verbal warnings the written warning etc
is that the drivers will realize that
the severity of the breach that they are
if they do breach it that they know
potentially they are going should not be
able to make deliveries to that's that
developed in the future difficulty aim
it's clearly laudable and it may work
but it's an aspiration it's about what
will happen in practice because if if
actually there isn't a proper sanction
or consequence that is actually
effective or going or can be effective
as it's then based on good willing you
may have lots of employees so you know
where people who like to stick to rules
and we will do so and we'll follow this
through you may have others who say to
you well actually we're struggling to
get drives at the moment we can't afford
to you know turn these people away so
I'm gonna have to turn a blind eye to
what I'm asking is in those
circumstances does the estate company
have an ability you know what can
actually do to employee presumably
you're not gonna say well you can't
occupy the building anymore no I take
your point and we have given it quite a
lot of thought but we perhaps haven't
thought the full detail through however
potentially this development could take
10 years to bring through we on the
illustrative master plan that they
should be showing 8 8 10 different units
if the first occupy on that site flats
this issue you're going to haul me up in
front of this committee and go you've
got you've got it wrong this is not
going to work because we have to come
back and and report on these things and
if it's not going well we're not going
to you'd be able to bring revert the
reserve matter through without being
absolutely stripped to the bone with
criticism so we're going to have to make
it work we fully understand the issue
here around traffic HCV traffic through
steadily it's
the fundamental key concern risk for us
through the three or four years work
we've been doing to bring this
application through so yeah we have to
make it work otherwise that that schemes
going to fall flat on its face
and council bonds did you want to say
something yes I was just sort of
thinking that the Biddeford some years
ago and in Welford we've asked the
building companies not to come in
between eight and nine and three and
four now as far as I know most of the
companies have applied because they know
where their drivers are or could be all
deliveries I'm just wondering the risk
concern over the school whether you
could do that a Biddeford school there
was 200 houses there which I'm sure the
Chairman knows and there was a condition
on there about when the lawyers could
come on when they couldn't come so it is
possible but I wondered about the school
that's wrong is the this school in
Macabre green yes well we don't invisi
HGVs coming from the south the majority
that that's an existing problem with
with you know there are issues with HGV
movements up and down the 8th or 3/5
which I'm nothing to do with the
developments here what we're saying is
we can manage the HTV traffic that will
be generated by this development through
the proposals that would outlined in
application council Richard did you want
to sorry my question was answered thanks
I think
well accepting this I think there are
some questions that have been raised
which are technical which can be asked
in a few moments the second is neon to
the other element which is they hide to
the buildings which was raised at the
last committee and the concern on the
residents are certainly far more laying
on the southwest of the site there I
appreciate what you've done at this
stage which is to move them backwards
and such right
however we are going to be coming
forward at some point if this is granted
with a reserve matters
have you any plans at this moment to set
up a working or steering group with the
residents to discuss the elements around
we're on would you be willing to do so
chairman we've not got any plans at
present residents clearly residents
clearly would have an opportunity to
comment on reserve mass applications
when they're submitted to the council
for consideration can I can I just
suggest as we've on some of our major
sites that we've had we have had these
steering groups with reserve residents
and the local councillors and suchlike
and they have been very beneficial to do
some smoothing waves we can certain
elements of the design can I just say we
have a project board that the chief exec
or bronzer already chairs
Kevin dicks and I know councillors have
been invited to that meeting and a
number of counselors have been involved
in that and we are we are looking to
continue those meetings going forward
should consent be granted we met with
the residents of long hope close there
was a spot spokesman there I can't
remember his full name but mark he lived
at number 8 we went to see him we
visited his house and talked it through
and that was part parcel of the change
that was made we did have a public
exhibition when our plans were published
and that was at the blue in motel I
think which is right by the site and a
large number of residents from when
Yates attended that and we discussed the
proposals with them if you're suggesting
that we need to do more of that going
forward when reserved matters happen
then my personally and I'm sure my
colleague we wouldn't have a problem
with doing that at all
excellent thank you they're on board any
other questions cottage ours
so you mine about trance how many
employer different employees is
anticipated roughly you're going to be
on site I know that might be difficult
question to answer
I appreciate but because obviously
you've got the bigger units which
obviously gonna like douse one but rough
ballpark well I think a number of
different sized units are shown on the
plan so I think it could be anything
from you know four to twelve cancers
thanks hopefully this would be my last
one um we'll talk to HTV sparked traffic
mushroom plan have you put any thought
to the management of the carts that come
in to and from the site well counselor
obviously we put the application in and
that's been assessed by the the highways
authorities we've not had a request
through the consideration of application
to introduce any particular routing plan
for for cars and I think in some
respects that is extremely difficult
you know you've raised issue already on
the ATVs and and query whether it's
possible to enforce it
to try and enforce it against a private
individual driving their own car I think
would be impossible simply and then I'll
make the suggestion perhaps and
carriages we can ask that of okay
so there's no there's no there's no
individual player in terms of managing
cars other than the provisions of our
travel plan which is obviously something
that we have to put in this pan pass the
application of tryna encourage people to
use alternative more sustainable modes
of transport than the car and now to
kept the application does provide for
additional bus stops and footpath
lectures the cycle path connections
thank you any other questions thank you
very much Natalie
our final speaker is Kelsey courage
nope you don't want me to okay thank you
just to say I'd have a lot of respect
for the applicants actually because I
have sat on that project board he
mentioned and they have worked very hard
with lots of different parties and they
have been very aware of the traffic
issues right from the beginning however
um I've seen that the information we got
about the HTV routing plan and and I've
got a complement the the Committee on
their their questions because it's
raised some issues I hadn't actually
thought of myself I'm not happy with the
detail we've got and I understand
there's time in the future to develop
that but I'm not happy now with the
detail we've got especially about the
enforceability I
I completely agree I don't see how as
proposed it will work and and I think
you need to see a way of how it will
work where there can be a real
consequence not just to a driver but to
the company they're responsible to so
that's the one thing and the other thing
about the travel plan several things
about the travel plan itself in fact I'm
not happy with the enforceability the
number of warnings you get before
anything actually happens as well that's
another thing you get a verbal warning a
written warning I dig gosh I mean but
you know the business we closed down
with the time they get around to
actually stopping them driving in so
that's that's the one thing they also
said that local traffic to redditch is
excluded from the travel plan I know it
doesn't make sense to me
because local traffic director could
come out of this development head south
on the a for 3-5 through map of a green
and enter just north of Studley at the
wash foot wash food mill where there's
other industrial estates and and I don't
know what the practical reasons are to
say what it should be all HGV traffic
from this side so they were mention of
some practical reasons I don't
understand that and I don't like
being excluded also on the traffic plan
it's there's one week every year where
they're going to look at numbers I think
that's fine and within that week there's
one day when they're going to do this
vehicle recognition thing to see if the
traffic's going through Studley now I
like the idea of that that seems like a
technical solution which which can work
but it's one day a year now I've put
this forward as you know maybe it should
be one day a month I've heard back that
maybe one day a month too much but one
day a year one day a quarter you know at
least if not every two months you know
we've got to know how this is happening
and the other thing that councillor
right mentioned is that this is only
proposed for five years after and after
the first occupation it's going to take
ten years before it's even fully built
out the bond is for fifteen years or a
year after final occupation
so again hazel rights are points on on
you know this is generational it should
be at least fifteen years that's only
you know that's the start of it the the
monitoring of HGVs right if it could
take ten years to build out you don't
want to stop monitoring a year after
that because they learned that can
happen we're talking about the future so
I think the monitoring should have a
long term life so I'm unhappy with
what's come before us although it's a
it's a lot better than what we had
before you raised the point about cars
nothing's being talked of as cars there
will be an impact there will be more
cars and nothing's being suggested about
that so so I'm against it at the moment
because I don't see the travel plan
working nothing mentioned about
increased cars which the will be and on
other matters on the existing conditions
we've got the indicative plan before us
for the southern plot it's not there now
and that has buildings with service
yards facing the south facing the
residential areas and that's an
indicator
I was very indicative and when you come
into reserved matters we're supposed to
look at all again but in a year in eight
years whenever it is when that comes
back to this committee and we probably
won't be on it that committee will look
at the indicative plan and say oh well
that looks all right let's just grant it
but I think we need to really stress
that you know this proposal is at the
midpoint in less earnest blues Council
those like so we've got the effect on
the local residents we've got effect on
the view from the a 435 we've got effect
on listed buildings of lights pollution
noise all of which we should make sure
is seriously considered at reserve
matters and I don't think we're strong
enough at this point to make sure that
people in the future when they're
considering this consider it properly
Thank You councillor any questions I
think we pick up the themes and we'll
certainly pick up some of the technical
questions yeah in the in the in the
vehicle routeing management plan their
power its proposed to look at where they
go i if they go through steadily or not
on one day a year only so that that's
just not good enough
if we were to approve the application
you would want that one once a month
once every two months I also once a
month you know and it's only there for
five years I think it needs to be there
for the long term okay Kelsey Jones have
you got your committee report with yeah
I'm just looking at page 17 because it's
a comment that you made in there and I
just wanted to explain because I didn't
quite understand it it was talking about
core strategy making it clear that
traffic impacts on Studley and Michael
were to be given much weight in the
decision the word significant is often
used but you talk and then you go on to
talk about significant should be
interpreted differently when considering
the a4 35 south of Gorka Hill and the
reasoning I just want if you can explain
yes I cannot I haven't got evidential
evidence before me
I think the some to some background
papers did the redditch plan when they
were they were discussing probably
development in in the read each side
alongside map of the green when they
were talking about building houses there
and and one of the traffic reports there
we was talking about well you know you
can go up to five percent increase in
traffic and and it's not significant but
the inspector I think at that time like
I don't know where so I'm afraid you
can't you can't look at it but it's my I
agree with him so it's my opinion that
when you've got a road which is full
already and troublesome already and
polluting already then you can't say
well you know there's only a bit you
know it's a bit more and compared to
everything that's there it's it's it
doesn't make any difference but it's
already too full so don't you can't add
any more to it to it to a glass which is
already full is my point it's already a
problem so anymore no matter what the
percentage is is is too much more okay
any other questions Thank You counsel
all right move over to technical
questions I'm gonna start with Alice she
don't really comfortable and ready to go
then say the just so I'm clear now that
all members are clear the this is set
the principle of this site has been set
in our core strategy am i right in
thinking it has been in the red each one
as well yes we'll start with that one
yes so to confirm it's been allocated
for Employment Development under both
Stratford and reddish and Bromsgrove
local plans
then there's a I've got so many
questions about this traffic routing
assessment I don't think we've got time
for them all now so I'll try and be
concise and keep them simple first of
all this two hundred thousand pound bond
well how did you get to that figure
where does it come from
so the two hundred thousand pound bond
is something that we've been working on
as a Highway Authority and that is based
on the cost of traffic regulation orders
to be implemented to restrict HGV
movements in air quality management
areas all bate with the introduction of
what environmental weight limits or
where we've got weak structures or a
height issue because that's how we can
control HTV looting the sim was
identified for the DB cemetery site up
at Magna Park and the adjacent Magna
Park site which was worked alongside
Leicestershire County Council about the
cost of how much money we would think we
need to fully implement TR though
changes to the highway network to
protect our communities so on that site
it was amongst Kirby Pelton threatening
divorce up in the north of Lubbock so we
I spoke to my colleague from
Worcestershire County Council on that
approach but we both felt the need that
it needs to be heavily conditioned at
the same time of a HTV routing strategy
and basically the two hundred thousand
pound bond is the stick to make sure
that developers do what they are saying
they are doing through the HTV routing
strategy if they aren't then the
condition comes in the council will
enforce that condition and the highway
authorities will use that money to go
and do the measures that we need to do
to protect our communities from
excessive HGV movements now that's in
relation to the development we have to
be careful about existing movements on
the network and also we are we have to
take the advice from how highways
England as well because whilst we may
not like it the i-435 corridor is a
diversionary route for both the m5 and
the m42 if there is an issue on those
routes and we must maintain free flow of
traffic along that route along as well
as the a46
well so we will engage with all parties
to do that and I know my colleagues in
transport planning are working on a
studly transport strategy to try and
work at more detail on that as well
which has been led by Nadine
as a Harley MP I'm going to keep going
if that's all right I'll tell you when
I'm done
so I I'm not fluent in highway and so
simplify what you've just said into
plain English from my benefit and I
think probably for most people in this
room's benefit what you're saying there
is that to understand as mahan bond is
to be it's if there are unforeseen
circumstances
once this if approved is implemented
that two hundred thousand be used for TR
OS and traffic management orders it was
that stand for
which means signage speed reductions
that sort of thing is that right it will
be weight limits height restrictions we
can do speed restrictions and look at
other measures which would discourage
hahdve utilizing those routes instead li
it's unlikely to go to traffic calming
measures because of the highways England
process and Alice mentioned to me that
little conditions in your report of a
seed so the highway conditions on page
76 are just a summary of what we want Y
can do is read you out the actual
conditions which were written jointly
with Worcestershire County Council is
that's helpful yeah you can't you can I
will be helpful but let's not do that
just yet because that might complicate
things a little bit of the state okay so
that's helpful on the two hundred we
talked about I think has a water water
enforceability and they examples of
where this has been thoughtful before I
know vehicle routeing measurement plans
are used extensively in development but
specifically something that would be
akin to this development have you got
anything that would support what's being
proposed
so deft at the be adjacent to look B has
a HGV routing strategy and they have a
NPR cameras on their access Arrangements
and that was accepted by the National
Infrastructure Commission that assessed
that planning the national planning
infrastructure
Commission I think it's called I might
be collected in that in a minute which
assess the application and that's
obviously a central government body that
assess that application in addition
Magna Park the existing Magna Park the
operators ID gays Li are working with
Myra on new technology of how to deal
with HGV routing they've got a MPR
cameras on their access as well and they
do do the cords of traffic movements
heading towards our villages in rugby
and they have to demonstrate that as
part of their expansion application but
they are working closely with my Rover
to develop further technology how we
manage and track HGV movements on the
network there's a lot of technology
coming out in this area so it is an area
where flux which we have to try and
sympathize with in terms of the HGV
routing strategy that's throwing up
another question supposed to be on that
and that adds to the list I've already
got and so this deft in rugby the
national infrastructure assessment
whether it was if we're money to approve
this and the quality management plan is
that the same body that will be or will
that same body be asked to approve this
one as well if not why not
or can we the reason that dearth was
granted by the National Infrastructure
Commission was because it was such a
large application so it was dealt with
by them rather than anyone planning
authority obviously this is
significantly smaller which is why us as
a planning authority can deal with it it
might be significantly smaller but it
impacts a significant proportion of our
district read each district and
Bromsgrove so it would be useful I think
to be able to put that to them and see
if they will give it the thumbs up is
that something we can do the
determination this application rests
with Stratford district councils the
determination of this application does
but the approval of the routing
management plan while still falls under
us can we have approval from them or at
least have their eye over it they're
clearly experts and the thing it would
make sense for them to do that we could
ask them to do it obviously we would be
relinquish control and authority as
would the highway authority if they did
say yes
so that's something you just need to be
well controlled relinquish if we're
asking them to give advice on the
routing strategy then they they would be
taking over on that point they're
experts in it does that not make sense
to have that they were mentioned by Ben
because they were the determining
Authority for the large infrastructure
of dirt I do understand that doesn't
necessarily mean they're experts in
highways Authority I think the way you
need to perceive it is that we use that
as the template that was that absolutely
we use it as a template that is the
template for this authority to review
the HTV routine structurally safe deem
it acceptable or not okay I will stop
laboring that point for the time being
the movement of cars so I get the point
that the applicant was making we can't
really control the movement of cars on a
public highway is there in your mind is
there anything that we can do as it has
appropriate consideration being given to
the number of cars that are going to be
coming to and from this site there is no
way you can manage the routing of
vehicles everyone pays their vote tax
exercise duty we are allowed to utilize
the public roads just as when we feel
like it when we like and how we like
that that is the way we pay our our
exercise duty for vehicles and that's
how the road network is maintained in
terms of travel planning the there is a
travel plan that will have to be
submitted to Worcestershire County
Council to promote sustainable modes of
transport to reduce the number of
vehicles if the site and the applicants
and the operators aren't meeting those
targets
Worcestershire County Council with
discussion with Warwickshire County
Council will go in to take necessary
measures or advise on what measures the
site should be taking to reduce the
number of vehicles on on that topic but
physically there's nothing we can
actually do to reduce the number to stop
people taking certain boots what your
County Council was rather concerned by
the modeling that was undertaken and the
view of the transport consultants at the
time about the impact on stood Lee Weyer
County Council did our own
assessment of the modeling in Studley we
utilize our own funds and our own time
to enter take that assessment and we did
a number of scenarios and assessments
throwing the kitchen sink at it
basically because I wanted to see it
what happened to the network it
demonstrated that with the growth
identified for rugby both in housing
numbers the Stratford growth as well and
and those for Birmingham as well that
the actual Studley corridor could
accommodate the reddish East in gateway
traffic however we were alive to the
facts with a HT existing HGV issue which
is currently being exacerbated by the
roadworks on the m5 with the throttling
of the m42 interchange and we asked for
mitigation to be considered in terms of
a chi region to try and protect that
community from this site the applicants
have done that and this brings us into a
difficult point with the MPP F because
we only consider what is severe based on
the impact of the development the MPP F
and the National Planning practice
guidance heads is notice DFT surfer to
2013 which says that an applicant or
developer only has to mitigate their
impact upon the highway network if there
isn't a case to demonstrate that there
is an impact on the network we cannot
class it as severe and therefore
technically under paragraph 32 we are
unable to object to a planning
application I get what counter the
carriage was saying about the five
percent but that was probably no offense
to the consultants in the room but
that's probably a consultant to want to
put forward their case or why that site
could come forward we as a warrior taker
view that if you have an impact
you must mitigate it they've
demonstrated to a certain extent that
they can mitigate it through the HTV
routing strategy and that's why the
highway Authority even with all our
modeling is had to move to and no
objection I work two more and then I'll
give someone else a chance I have been
first and that's why I say talk me
through this new Junction and how it
works
it looks extraordinarily complicated to
me someone did talk it through with me
last time but I need reminding how is
the question that's going to come to you
in a minute is about the monitoring for
five years or one year or permanent
what what exactly is being proposed in
terms of the junction of management and
there are a number of options to be
looked at
one was a roundabout but due to the land
difference levels in that area we can
actually get a roundabout in so we've
had to adopt a signalized junction
because that can be accommodated within
the highway boundary but also is
acceptable in Dar be standards with
minimal departures from that to be
acceptable
now departures are a normal process and
they all signed off by the head of
service at what you count to council my
glider based on the technical approval
process and of the Highways Act so
they've got to go through a lot more
detail yet this is a preliminary design
and we'll go through further detail that
so this but it's a signalized junction
we're staging it's been Lin it's been
assessed in worcestershire z-- visit
model watcher counts counsels ask for a
very detailed Lin seek assessment which
is a stand-alone junction a special
assessment of the junction and is
demonstrated it operates with spare
capacity minimal cueing and minimal
delay we've also consulted with the road
safety team who considered the access
arrangements and also had input into its
design at this stage and provided
comments about where signage is needed
on the approach to that Island Island
approach to that junction in terms of
full visibility from the i-435 so people
are aware of coming in but neither what
none of our technical department as
watcher County Council where this sits
have raised an objection to Mae about
the access arrangements so ultimately
you're entirely satisfied that this will
work and function as it should and as
planned yes thank you so coming back to
the question in terms of monitoring and
the frequency of fact and I think Ben
was going to start to get into it in
terms of talking you through the
specific wording of the conditions in
the report they are just proceed so if I
turn to the suggested wording in terms
of the surveys which i think is
specifically what you're interested so
the wording is annual HDV surveys will
be submitted to the local planning
authority to demonstrate the
implementation and operation of the HTV
routing strategy the methodology shall
be submitted and approved in writing
before they are undertake
with both Worcestershire and
Warwickshire highway authorities the
first of mission will take place 12
months from first occupation of the
phase of the granted plan and permission
so basically that does require a
methodology should be submitted to us
for approval
so although the developers may have
suggested one day a year for a period of
five years that's not necessarily going
to mean that that's what happens that
would be something which the highway
authorities will look at very carefully
when we come to discharge in that
condition to make sure that it's for a
reasonable length of time which I think
I'll come back to Ben for a moment for
some a little bit more clarity on and in
terms of how often we are undertaking
those surveys would you want to identify
a frequency and time at this stage or do
you know not not not while we're having
this discussion no there might be
something in my mind to bring up a
debate but I think we'll wait until we
get to that so just just for clarity
before you bring been in and I do want
I'm really sorry too but I do want to
ask about enforceability in a second as
well
and this one day a year for five years
is the problem is what's been proposed
by the applicants but that's not
necessarily what we're going to accept
as an authority did Ben wants a comment
yeah at the moment the the condition
doesn't have an end date the reason that
is that we thought we'd keep this in
perpetuity so it when actually you're
discharged but obviously applicants
might want an end date on it it may feel
that's overly onerous but obviously
that's for you as a committee to decide
whether end date is acceptable or not
but condition seven as Alice is just
without goes hand in hand with condition
six which is the one before it which
we've stated the moment and some of this
wording may change the development here
by committee shall not be brought into
use until the applicant has submitted to
and had improved in writing by the local
planning authority a heavy goods vehicle
routeing strategy that prevents HTV
movements traveling south and impacting
on the villages of Studley and map no
green identifying to the two core
villages a clear diagram shall be
provided identifying the votes with
agreed measures and monitoring
procedures demonstrated
the plan shall be implemented and
monitored in accordance with its terms
in the event of failing to meet these
requirements a revised plan shall be
submitted to and be improved in writing
by the local planning authority to
address any shortfalls and where
necessary make provision for and
identify mitigation for impacted
communities the plan thereafter shall be
implemented and updated in agreement
with the local planning authority so
that's as each as each unit taken or
unit changes the HTV routing plan has a
flexibility of change but it would have
to be considered by the planning
authorities once again when you say
changes so it's not a if it's a new
client takes over that particular
facility that kicks in it immediately it
can do if they feel that the existing
HTV routing strategies doesn't meet
their needs or the management company
does or if we find an issue through the
annual HTV services we can ask for that
condition to be enforced by Stratford or
the other and the other authorities to
ask for the HTV routing strategy to be
reviewed almost done almost done
honestly so with the with the load you
said local playing authority in this
instance there are three so it needs to
be approved by all three and also by
county and what's there and watch can
see in terms of the traffic side is that
right so are basically a five-way
agreement so when it comes to enforcing
this whose shoulders does it fall upon
does it fall upon ours does it fall upon
redditch Bromsgrove Wooster Warwickshire
or all five if I could come in on that
one the developers to develop the site
will need all three planning permissions
or planning permission from each
authority once it's up and running any
one of those authorities could enforce
obviously Stratford's got the larger
area and if the impact is on the
Stratford board or town then you would
expect that outfit to take it but it's
not certain read it you could do it
Bromsgrove could do it equally but it
would fall to the planning authority
because it's a planning permission
okay and this is it so how do we enforce
them so we've got a list of disciplinary
breaches or discipline eight
disciplinary system how are we gonna are
we going to have access to these am PR
this am PR day to the tracking day sir
are we going to have a list of who's
been reprimanded as a result of a breach
of that house how is that gonna work
I've seen nothing in here to tell me how
that's no one correct me if I'm wrong
that will be provided to us we will be
able to request it and if there are
breaches and we're not satisfied with
that we ultimately could serve a breach
of condition notice which is obviously a
breach of that then is a criminal
offense so that's the ultimate sanction
just to add to what we just said the
reason we're going down this route is
that the management company alone for
the site isn't strong enough for the
enforcement of the HGB routing strategy
the planning legislation in the process
that we operate gives us the greatest
tools for the highway authorities to
enforce this we don't let Steve and
collect me don't have any powers under
the highways act 1980 to deal with HGV
routing it's mainly under the Town and
Country Planning Act 1990 now and those
specific enforcement measures so we're
doing this to make sure we've got the
strongest case to make the sure this
works
counselor bonds first then Council Jules
yeah I forgot my mask
sorry
both ward members mentioned this once a
year monitoring in the village can we
change that or the conditions that was
picked up that was picked up just a
moment ago saying that the the
developers have proposed this one-day
assessment within on the highway network
the condition states that the
methodology of that has to be agreed
with both highway authorities and then
approved by the three local planning
authorities we can take of you and
obviously committee can give us steer
this evening of what they want to see
those annual surveys or when those
surveys
place or how often so I can put a
condition on if I want yeah okay castle
Giles just in terms of this
enforceability point in breach of
condition so say we were satisfied that
it would who would be in breach would it
be management company on behalf of
developer or is it the occupier and
stroke owner the planning permission
would run with the land so ultimately it
would be the landowner that's
responsible but correct me if I'm wrong
here
you could also prosecute an occupier if
you had evidence that they were part of
that breach of the breach of condition
notice if that makes sense that's
correct you could prosecute the owner or
the person responsible for the breach or
both can I just pick up a point that was
made by councilor carriage about going
alternate routes into red edge he was
talking about going down the 435 through
my abroad to wash hood and then going in
to register that way how's that being
considered in your routing strategies
through you chairman the condition
requires the route to be agreed and the
plan to be submitted so yes it has been
agreed the information how something has
been put forward but ultimately
alternatives are still up the debate so
we can consider those as needed thank
you sir cancel boarding thanks chair in
terms of the three local plans that were
mentioned are we aware of what highways
evidence was put before those three
planning inspectors like was it was it
just the developers evidence was as BOMs
Grove that was Wooster highways as well
as Warwickshire highways and someone
else put evidence before those because
and then my follow up is then we've
obviously got highways here at Warren
County Council whatever evidence they
had versus what is informed I do accept
us informed resident opinion
and valid and hearty but but is there
any evidence formal evidence from a from
a transport organization that
contradicts without looking at the
evidence that was put before I can
obviously only speak on behalf of
Stratford not ready to a Bromsgrove but
without looking at the evidence that was
put before the local planet the call
strategy inquiry for Stratford I'm
unable to answer your question what I
would say is obviously any evidence that
would have been given at that core
strategy inquire would have been taken
into account by the planning inspector
and the weight obviously that needs to
be given at this stage is obviously to
the development plan a the core strategy
that gets the greatest weight as the
allocation but in question I can't say a
certain that there was no evidence
professional evidence that came forward
from any local residents can be honest
just wanted to ask about the diffe site
is that is it sort of one big employer
or logistics company cited there or is
it multi in the way I know it's a bigger
scale but is it a multi sort of oak in
the way this so yeah and both magnet
Park and those sites which I reference
are multi occupier sites so dirt has the
benefit of a rail head which serve some
of the units on there but magnet Park is
all road based but it is a mixture of
units so large logistic companies like
DHL or you might have warehousing for
large like supermarkets or or big stores
like that so they're all individual
occupiers but they tend to have an
overall management company across the
whole site just a quick one on the bond
I don't if I picked this up correctly
but I think the bond expires if that's
right terminology one year after the
final client is is installed is that
correct no that's not correct it's
actually 15 years Bromsgrove District
Council committee decided to include
the timeframe from 10 years to 15 from
and it would be helpful
occupation of the last unit on the site
so the payment has been provided on
first occupation it's held as the site's
build-out and not occupied but then can
be held for a further 15 years after
that site it's for a full occupation so
I believe the developer said it could be
10 years as the site's built out or 5
years you've got then 15 years
you got occupying it and then 15 years
on top of that so there is a long term
solution we're holding that money for
quite some time okay thank you hm lot
I've just got two questions you'll be
pleased to know cursory in relation to
two highways having looked at this
technical document yes I think I've got
the grit proof of it I am however
concerned about traffic coming to the
site from the south I get that we can
use all sorts of high-tech to get
drivers to use the advisory words but
I'm thinking of a articulated lorry
coming north from London wanted to get
to this site it's going to get to
Junction 15 of the long bridge island
then it's going to use the a4 189
through three or four small rural
villages to get to this site via the
mapable Green Island I don't see
anything here that would prohibit that
happening because a driver whoever it
might be the sat-nav will tell him to go
that way
and they'll put a lot of pressure on
some very very narrow rural routes I
mean the four one eight nine is a trunk
road it's already a pretty massive
capacity and I'm just concerned that
this this proposal would add to that if
you could comment on whether it is
possible to control that type of thing
the eight four one eight nine isn't as
peripheral as the m-40 m42 corridor that
is the fastest corridor with the HGVs
coming off at Junction 3 I do take your
point though when there are issues on
the m-40 m40
viii 4189 can be utilized it hasn't been
flagged as an issue in terms of our
assessment we did raise a few with the
road safety at the dog roundabout
however with the HTV routing strategy
and mitigating that impact we and yeah
the accident local not really being
there we aren't able to get an
improvement on that Junction I think
we'd have to I think based on your
concerns you could consider that as well
you feel that's a necessary route to
perhaps be considered as part of the HTV
routing strategy and the monitoring
process that's been identifying those
two conditions are identified so just
that I understand at a later stage this
this particular aspect could could be
considered by this committee or would it
be an officer's basically I'm saying
that if you feel it's necessary it can
be can include it within the condition
for the annual surveys and that ensures
that it is considered within the
methodology for for that loot of I
stated that we identified macular green
and studly on the a four three five
corridors but if you feel that the a
four one eight nine within proximity to
map Bluegreen I have to save close
proximity map the green should be also
assessed then you can include that in
the condition if that's your view of
deferred to Richard if you think that's
acceptable
okay thanks a second question this is
really to Alice and it addresses my
concerns that are still here about the
height of the buildings on the southern
part of the site I'm delighted to see
that the developers have given way with
the the hatched area and actually moving
the the buildings away 21 meters is a
tall building in anyone's reckoning
distribution parts like this yes there
are some that are higher than 21 meters
I will accept but an awful lot of the
modern estates in and around the West
Midlands this area you know it's quite
normal to see
buildings of 15-meter eaves heights not
as big as is because of the proximity of
the houses
I could probably accept 15 meters but 21
is it possible for us to condition that
this in a moment but if we just grant
that as it stands is it then basically
can't branch for these buildings which
presumably will be designed and build
for the developer to offer
this height yeah we would still have the
control through reserve matters to look
at the detailed design and in line with
that detail design consider again the
impact on neighboring residential
amenity obviously at this stage is only
the parameters Luna's I would stress at
this stage is obviously in terms of the
separation distances as shown on the
plan here we've got the sixty-eight
point two meters here that's to the edge
of the development zone you've then got
a 15 meter distance here of the 50
meters in height then going up to 21
meters here so I've conducted the
council's twenty five degree line from
this dwelling here which is at the
closest point so that's in our extending
your home advice note which is only
guidance but provides a good indication
of how to assess overbearing
overshadowing and it's significantly
complied with both 21 metres and 15
metres so I would appreciate that the
the may be an impact on well there will
be an impact on the view of the
properties in terms of looking over the
site but the resultant impact in terms
of overbearing and loss of light in
officers view is more than acceptable at
the height proposed coming back to your
point in terms of can we condition that
it's lower we've got to consider the
application as currently proposed
obviously the developers have gone away
and have reduced the heights to make it
even better in terms of the relationship
to the neighbors so it so it's on this
basis that the application needs to be
determined on point about quality design
and the quality design at the reserve
matter stage can we influence shall we
say the roof
lines because quite often a very square
roofline is quite obtrusive whereas I
noticed that some of the ones with a
sort of wavy wavy roof lines a
significant leap I'll use the word
easier on the eye but they show I'm
coming from at that point it's obviously
something in terms of that we can look
at to look to secure reserved matter
stage obviously the developers are here
so they'll know your comments in terms
of how we were maybe looking for
slightly more innovative design any
reserved matters submission would have
to come through planning committee and
last counselor carriage in the Chairman
agreed for it to be dealt and the parish
council agreed for it to be delegated so
you would at that stage have chance to
review any design and obviously we can
highlight to the developers through any
engagement prior to submission that some
sort of innovative design is is what
we're hoping to achieve
obviously through poor strategy policies
yes and I'm really looking for high
quality design anyway thank you so at
Meserve matters essentially if
developers come along with proposal for
21 meter high buildings the grant of
this am i right has any what you're
saying is the brunt of this means that
we're really we're gonna probably gonna
have to accept that we're not going to
turn on to say well actually no we want
15 meter high buildings along there I
just mean it was a matter stage once
we've got the detailed design if there's
any specific reason why we think it
would cause overbearing or loss of light
or noise impacts say for example if it
does due to the location service yards
which we don't currently know we do
think it will cause issues in that
regard then that is something which we
consider it reserved matters stage I
think the thing to note is that the
neighbor tests on a worst case scenario
basis in terms of thinking of them at
maximum Heights are complied with so it
will in that regard likely to be
acceptable but obviously it will be
completely dependent on the detailed
design it was there matter station a
thorough assessment will take place at
that stage the reason I'll consider is
because sometimes what you get is when
we get to negotiating reserved matters
it
he said well outlined it was agreed you
know there has been a plan a master plan
and essentially it's been agreed there
will be 21 meter buildings here and
there will be up to 21 meters there and
up to 15 here and so actually it's not
unreasonable for them to put that
forward in therefore there's no
reasonable objection to it is that going
to be the argument that's made if
there's a reasonable planning reason as
to why we want to raise objection to the
design at reserve matter stage even if
it complies with the parameters then
there's no reason that we can't object
to it or refuse it on the basis of
contravening local plan policies this
would this used be used as a counter
argument to say this is essentially
committee has already approved that in
principle the plan is proposed involves
buildings outside of the hatched area
there that can be up to a maximum of 21
meters that doesn't mean that they will
be 21 meters and for the mass majority
of this site as with any site most of
the buildings will be below that level
but it allows them that flexibility to
go up to that level and as Alice just
said that doesn't mean that we don't
have to then consider the usual planning
considerations at reserve matters the
impact on the landscape the visual
impact and also the impact on the
neighbors all it means is is they can go
up to 21 meters where they desire that
pick on counter Joe's point as well I
think this is becoming more imperative
that we do have a steering group element
to this part of the design as well
Katalin I'm sorry okay and the other
technical questions no okay thank you
well I think that was some very good
questions and thank you very much indeed
all right I'm gonna open it up for
debate now
yes cancer it is indicated ages ago so
I'm going to focus my my comments now on
on the transport on that and the vehicle
routing management stuff
what was what was put in front of us
through this briefing note as as I
mentioned before has given me no further
information than was given to us at our
at the last committee meeting albeit
last time it was verbal now it's written
down so it is giving me no reassurance
as to exactly how management of the how
the traffic and the HTV movements are
going to be managed properly what
compounded that concern was a comment
made by one of the applicants and I
wrote this down he said with perhaps
we've not thought through the full
detail and that reaffirmed our decision
to defer in December and actually I
still don't think we've got sufficient
detail here so that puts us in a very
difficult position was the principle of
the site has already been established
through our core strategy I'm still
uncomfortable with the way in which this
the traffic of the site or the effect
it's going to have is being considered
and managed and we have a choice now we
can either refuse the planning
application on that basis and then risk
an appeal if we do that and they'll be
successful we have then no or limited
control over exactly how this vehicle
routeing management is going it's going
to come forward the the other option
that I would put two members for
discussion in this debate is if we were
minded to grant given the principal has
already been set for the development but
request or condition a vehicle routeing
measurement plan to come back to this
committee for full scrutiny is that
something that we will be minded to
support I'm I'm gonna put that out and
see what the feel is by members but I
think those realistically those are our
two options on that notwithstanding that
clearly there'll be issues in terms of
design Heights and things like that but
that's where I'm coming from I'll leave
it open for anyone else because the buzz
was first I do apologize yes sir I
obviously didn't know what cancer
Richard you can't say but I like you
have cancer
and that we haven't actually got all the
information that we were hoping for I
don't think we can defer it again but
because it's in the core strategy both
County Council's are supporting it
Bromsgrove supporting it and and so is
Redditch so I would be quite happy to go
along the lines that have just been
proposed in the respective how many
times it's monitored in in steadily and
and so that we can keep abreast of it to
the point where it actually gets to
detail plans otherwise I can't see them
Illusionist appeal because everything
more said at the core strategy meetings
the road was brought there I did see I
were there for part of the town and so
I'm happy to support cancer Rich's him
he's thought cause of Jones before look
at some detailed issues I think this is
the first time I've seen its application
I wasn't sitting on committee and from a
general observation I have to say this
application it leaves one with a quite a
disappointed feel about how our planning
system works because what we've clearly
got is we're told that this is a local
plan that is approved by three districts
no less yet what is completely obvious
from all the comments and everything
that's been said here is it doesn't
enjoy local support it has numerous
objection from district councillors in
Stratford local to this area it has
objection from district council in the
reddit area it has objection from
several parish councils it has heritage
concerns raised it has concerns raised
from Wildlife Trusts concerns raised
about impact on listed building and I
think what this shows is we have a local
plan system which doesn't work because
essentially what it does is it provides
things in general terms
and then when the actual impacts become
known we have a lot of concern raised
that's when local residents become
engaged but it's too late because
actually what this committee will be
told in law is essentially this is a
proposal which is is approved in
principle by virtue of being in the
local plans and I can fully understand
why then you have whole series of people
who become completely dis disenchanted
with how local democracy and local
planning process works so I have to say
we've we focused a lot on one very tiny
aspect of this application which is
traffic and I appreciate there may have
been other matters debated at this
committee I wasn't sitting on but the
reality is there are numerous concerns
and for example we heard we've paid
scant attention to what is a huge
concern which is the increasing effects
of diesel pollution the fact that we
have a site which is right next to you
know stump I can look at this we have an
employment site which yes I can see why
in many ways it's appealing it's on the
edge of a built-up area it's near a
motorway network but let's be real this
is putting huge amounts of of pollutants
noise light pollution next to where
hundreds and hundreds of people and
children live you know you can
understand why people just stand back
and say well actually hang on a minute
does this make sense so I have to say
from in general terms and for other
reasons I'm deeply uncomfortable as the
application when we look at the actual
detail and all of the impacts it will
have because what we have to say is yes
of course it delivers a huge employment
benefit and I understand that but there
is obviously the concern and I've seen
it expressed so you know several times
throughout the comments in these papers
which is well actually it's quite easy
in a way to say let's put all our
employment stuff in one area because we
can just it's easier to plan in a way
but actually it's much harder work to
identify lots of little sites you know
little redevelopments you know putting
other you know sites into you know
redevelopment and perhaps having less
impact on residents so anyway so there
are several aspects that I feel unhappy
about including you know impact on local
residents pollution listed building so
on and so forth and then we look at we
focused
in a lot of detail on the transport
elephant elements and it gives me a lot
of disk whites as well because we are
told by residents and I am inclined to
agree that there's going to be huge
traffic impact formulas it's just common
sense and do we feel confident as a
committee that those have been robustly
dealt with bearing in mind the
significance of the impact of this
particular development and I don't feel
that confident about it now I don't
thank you I use the phrase we are where
we are the problem is and it cancer gels
doesn't like it but there are three
local plans that have approved this in
principle which is a problem for us as a
climbing committee I have some sympathy
with with councillor Richards proposals
I'm I was hugely disappointed by given
we would come back here today I wasn't
the first meeting come back to hear
about the transport strategy you know
what is what is this mitigating
circumstances they're going to make this
not as horrible as everyone assumes that
it will be and frankly I didn't think we
made any progress on that at all so I
suppose just the guidance I'm looking
for is if one was to approve this in
principle subject to the issues that are
still pity there on highways is that if
that came back to committee does that
have the weight that if we just still if
they come back and it's it's the same
cranky shambles sort of presentation
about highways and we still don't like
it can we block the development despite
the fact we approve its subject to
highways today I don't know how much
authority does this committee have when
it comes back if we think that we still
need a lot of work done on mitigation it
comes back it will be dealing with the
question of secured by condition the the
routing strategy that's what committee
will be considering not the principle of
the development so committee would be
considering whether the routing strategy
is acceptable if I gets caught up so so
if it's subtweet and say and we decide
whatever is subsequently
so let's say six months a year whenever
it is and we still don't like it
and we object them now does that stop
the development going ahead subject so
obviously they have the right to go and
appeal our reasons for blocking their
mitigation strategy that's correct
because the routing strategy has to be
approved prior to the occupation of the
development so if we don't approve it it
can't be occupied subject to their right
of appeal they can commence building it
yeah Thank You chairman I have great
difficulty with this I still don't think
there's enough comfort for me personally
on the management of the highways
Council Richard's made a good point
about the private cars and yes we
understand that cars can go wherever
they want but this is a little bit of
thought needed on that too my view what
concerns me more though is the proposals
here to build such tall buildings so
close to a residential amenity this is
better than it was before but I'm
looking at the yellow and the orange
sites on the north part of the site and
I'm wondering to myself why can't those
sites be transmogrified good word to the
south part of the site to at least give
the residents of Winn Yates some level
of of better amenity and that's why I
ask the question is whether I can't go
with this unless I can condition that
based on what I've heard from debates so
far you alluded to a steering group for
sites of a similar size and nature with
we have had steering groups set up it
seems to make sense particularly given
the comments that councilor jars made
over environments and other assessments
that need to be given to this that we
have a steering group set up that would
include cancers ward members parish
councils in order to really get to the
bottom of this so
a condition perhaps that has that sets
out that the needs that's there in group
I'm trying to think of wording too so
that it's gender it's responsible then
for the sort of the build out almost
like that the design and this size and
all that sort of stuff is that something
that a we can do and be the counselors
would be supported of a supportive of
and and also if you can give me some
guidance and as to whether we include
the traffic management plan within that
or whether we have that separate and
brought back to this committee I think I
wanted to come back to this committee
anyway but whether we have it included
or separate just a little bit of
feedback on that be helpful okay in
terms of a potential steering group
which would steer the the final design
and other elements of reserved matters
that that could be controlled it
couldn't be done by a condition but it
could be done by a note with the
ultimate sanction being obviously with a
note it can't force the developer to do
that but they're running the risk of a
stroke refusal on the reserve matter at
this committee later if they haven't
done that so I think it's quite safe
that if you put it on as a note you can
set your expectations out as to what the
steering group will look at and what its
remit would be okay if I may follow up
in that case I'm at where I'm at I have
sympathy for the comments accounts Giles
made over the the way in which members
of public and have become disillusioned
disenfranchised by the manner in which
local plans have been brought forward
the fact is it it has been brought
forward so you know the principal has
already been set so with that in mind
and given the extreme lack of detail
that has come forward about this vehicle
management plan which is the whole point
of bringing it back tonight and I would
propose that we do grant
however we add
note about the steering group and at the
conditions for the traffic management
plan conditions it that the developers
are required to bring it back to this
committee and I'd almost be inclined to
have that discussed as part of the
steering group before it comes back to
us I'm looking at our offices to give us
guidance on that I would like to some
involved rosters gonna talk to me yeah
the routing strategy needs to be
approved by the council so that's up to
our own internal procedures how we give
that approval if we if you wants us to
bring it back to committee we can do I
wants us to bring it back to committee
definitely I think that developers in
the agent are under no illusion that
they need to engage with us with the low
with the parish councils with the local
residents to make sure they get this
right because at the moment it is
lacking in all detail well that's what I
was saying very early on was the exactly
that reason I think that the communities
may feel and I'm probably justifiably
that they don't get involved in these
processes this is what we should be
doing at a far earlier stages to involve
people in this produce decision
processing I appreciate we are as close
aboard you said we are where we are with
this one there is the applications
before us it is within three local plans
as well we must make the best of this
what we possibly can
cows bones yes I was I'm happy to second
the proposal but what I'm thinking of is
that bring many many years ago and other
places that we've had where has been to
be development we've added liaison in
the respective is this committee that
you're thinking a bit like she's a
quarry I appreciate that but when the
law is went the wrong way then people
knew
whose report they had there was a system
that was in the old day before we had
sat-nav so I think it's something local
a steering group is essential to keep
abreast of it I'm quite happy - okay
thank you appreciate it second that but
this liaison thing is something that you
know I need the word you have or dream
again it's just Thank You cherica's
clarification council Lawtons point on
the height is that 21 meter height set
in local plans so so we could condition
a height less than 21 meters on the
basis of its impact
no we don't you're deciding the
application as it's currently proposed
so we get the opportunity reserved
matters to consider the detailed design
but at this stage we are accepting the
principle of up to 21 meters but as rich
to myself as vies earlier that doesn't
mean to say that 21 meters across the
entirety of the site is going to be
acceptable we will have to carefully
consider the impact on neighbors against
policy cs9 when a reserved matters
submission comes in thank you right any
other items for debate well I have a
proposer and I have a seconder on this
one
just ask accounts advanced or a bit of
clarity over what you're saying about
liaison was that specifically about that
transport or was that about the design
that's doing group well it was typically
about transporting in the respect of the
one that I said took twenty odd years
ago so I think two elements to this yeah
we need to go right before we take a
vote so so the proposal the project
proposal have put forward still stands
what I want to ensure is that when this
does come back to this committee the the
traffic management plan does give
sufficient detail to what we what we're
seeking so it might be worth having
either you as the chairman to
liaison with that group so we understand
you understand and you can input into
that based on our our concerns this one
year and one day in a year for five
years it's just absurd the perpetuity
thing I thought was a I think perpetuity
is more akin to what were wanting and
almost daily NPR should be on all the
time Don the 29th of February as well so
that's that's where I'm at the proposal
I just want that noted and understood
and clear but that's that's all about
that but also it's the impact of the
plaintiff on that makes that's the this
needs to be clear that really the
reality of what they're voting for is
approving that parameters plan which is
that it's okay for buildings of up to 21
meters to be there and that's obviously
going to be an argument used in due
course during reserve matters and
actually in my view is not acceptable
and and I don't accept that the guidance
you know our neighbor guidance about 25
degrees and 21 meters of separation
distance can have any applicability in
situations like this because that
applies to small household developments
on the whole I can't believe that that
that kind of guidance can really be
looked at in proper context when we're
talking about huge buildings in the
scale of a huge employment zone because
clearly in my mind they have a much
greater impact on much larger numbers of
people and actually there is those sort
of distances don't become relevant in my
view in terms of overbearing this
because this is about the general over
barrenness of all of the noise all of
the light pollution all of the the
impact of the buildings as a whole and
as a group so I think it's a more wider
consideration than just what's the
distance what's the 25 degree angle in
my personal opinion thank you very much
right and we do have it closed in a
second to finish on now sorry I'm
terribly sorry sorry no no come
please thank you however we have got a
number of items that need to be
discussed bye bye Richard
so could you that the items we've been
debating Jack I think could you bring
this forward if or it does just to
ensure the note is correct when there's
brought forward and to help with counsel
that point counsel Giles has just made
my note did specify that the heights
accessor are to be determined through
that staring group there's not set in
stone here tonight it's to be determined
through that staring group so that
before you go to the vote chair so that
I've understood there's been a lot set
and there's a lot of options on the
table here what I proposed to do is with
reference to the update sheet where you
can see under the first item updated
recommendation I will read out what I
understand members to be asking in terms
of the revised recommendation as I
understand it the subject to the one and
the two remain the same but then it
effectively changes to the planning
manager be authorized to grant this
hybrid planning application subject to
the conditions and notes as detailed in
the agenda with the exception of
condition 19 regarding the vehicle
routing management plan and condition 20
regarding annual HDTV surveys which
shall be brought back to the relevant
planning committee that those with
conditions in terms of notes it then
goes on to say and the following
additional notes note one the District
Council will expect to see full
pre-application engagement with local
stakeholders and Council T's as part of
the drawing up of the final reserve
matter schemes this process is likely to
be controlled by a steering group and
will have particular regard to the
relationship between the development
site and its residential neighbors
particularly where it adjoins the
southwest and southern boundaries of the
southern development parcel the district
planning authority will also
expect high quality and an innovative
design the steering group will also look
at the details to be drawn up and for
eventual approval by this committee or
the relevant committee in terms of
condition 19 vehicle rating management
plan and condition 20 annual HDTV
surveys oh sorry and the final note
which is already on that note 3 would
effectively become the work chef are in
rescue note seeking clarification that
two points in one stage miss Cardew you
talk about likely that a steering group
would do it are we saying that they
steering we would do it and then
secondly I do think we need to have some
definition remove what comprises a
steering group on the basis that I've
sat on to one of which had residents one
of which didn't have residents and I
think clearly in this situation it needs
to be a steering group that we are
saying we'll have resident resident
participation okay well so I was gonna
pick up on the likely thing as well I'm
glad you did we every steering group set
up by this council requires terms of
reference within those terms of
reference that would include the
stakeholders that are required I don't
think it's for this committee to set
those states sorry to set those terms of
reference I'm looking to my legal
officer and the plan officers to tell me
whether that's right or not but I think
that would set up outside there
certainly is a clear indication as to
who those stakeholders should be and who
should be in attendance thank you
that's correct I think the terms of
reference can be set up outside another
committee right no cancer are you happy
with the I'm I'm I'm in totally with the
conditions as they've been set and what
have you
I'm still this way I'm happy with what's
been presented to us tonight but in
terms of a recommendation I'm happy
council bars you still happy to second
this yes
Thank You members the vote before use to
grant planning permission for 1701 84 7
/ out as reddish Gately with all the
conditions and notes that have been
identified already read out by the
planning manager all those in favor
against to again thank you this
committee therefore resolved to grant
planning permission for 17 / 0 1 8 4 7 /
out thank you very much indeed or we'll
take a five-minute break now
thank you everybody thank you very much
I'd like to move on now to our next item
thank you everyone thank you thank you
very much
next item is 70s - oh 132 9/4 which is
kissing tree house and over to you thank
you the application site is identified
with the black dots on the map and is
located within Alveston village which
lies to the east of stratford-upon-avon
the application relates to two parcels
of land which outlined in red x' on the
map and are located within the grounds
of the grade 2 listed property known as
kissing tree house which is located here
kissing tree house is set within
extensive grounds part of which form the
formal curtilage and part the remainder
which lie to the south form and their
parkland setting to the property and
also the surrounding village so this is
more than a residential curtilage here
in the parkland to the south this site
lies within the Alveston conservation
area identified by the pink line here
and extends southwards so the entirety
of the site is in contained with it and
the property known as kissing Tree Lodge
is located to the east together with two
outbuildings which are currently being
converted into dwellings a single
dwelling plot again into construction
property known as even more cottage and
then to the west is the st. James's
Church which is identified with a red
outlining here which is also a great -
listed property to the north like
additional residential properties
and also to the east here rely lies also
additional residential dwellings turning
now to the elements of the application
there are a number of elements as I say
relating to the two parcels of land
starting with the northern mark most
part so two dwellings are proposed
firstly in filling an ornamental pond
erecting two dwellings and creation of a
haha along the southern boundary of the
site additional planting is also
proposed tree blackbell planting located
in this area here and the existing or
ornamental wrought iron gates which
contain the existing access to kissing
tree house are proposed to be relocated
to kissing tree lane the axis because
there is an existing vehicle access also
to the site of this of this Lane and
it's proposed to reintroduce the main
vehicle access - kissing tree house off
kissing tree lane which historically was
in situ in also in order to enable that
a change of use of land of this parkland
is proposed in order to create a
residential driveway land identified in
green either side is still proposed to
be retained as parkland and then there's
alterations as well - kissing tree lane
entrance which I'll show you in a moment
turning now to the dwellings the
dwellings are proposed to be full bed
units with integral garage bays
positioned either side of the existing
access
which is proposed of kissing treeway the
dwellings are contemporary in their
design and they are proposed to be
single-story flat roof structures
measuring 3.6 meters in height they
proposed to be constructed from a mix of
white render and timber cladding
siberian larch and a dark grade PPC
aluminium roof capping turning now to
photographs of the sights so this is
looking in the northernmost section so
part a will refer to it to us and this
is looking in the south easterly
direction
kissing treehouse is just out of shot
and and so one of the dwellings is
proposed to be located behind the wall
here and also the existing tree belt
along oval abutting kissing tree lay a
sari - kissing tree way is proposed to
be retained looking now in a
northwesterly direction so the church is
screened from the shot but these are the
wrought iron gates that's are proposed
to be relocated and again one of the
plots is proposed to be situated within
this area here you can just about see
the ornamental pond which is going to be
infilled now this is within the site
itself so you got the picture of this in
James's church which is into the West so
a dwelling is proposed to be located
within this area here and then the
second dwelling on the other side of the
access drive here so this existing hard
stanga's is proposed to be removed and
reached over so this ornamental pond is
going to be removed together with these
outbuilding structures and then this is
a view looking at kissing tree house
itself and so the second dwelling would
be located within this vicinity
this is a view showing James's church
and the existing haha and the park plan
so you can see the different ation
between the amenity space associated
with cutting treehouse and then the park
land beyond turning now to the second
element of the application as it works
oh this apart that call this apart B so
this is the proposed new access so this
is the relocated gates wrought iron
gates with two new pillars either side
there are existing pillars here for
which are going to be removed there's
existing closed boarding fence along
here which is also proposed to be
removed and replaced with the state
railings and then within the site itself
so within this area here is existing
walling internal war link which is
proposed to be breached and new gates
also inserted along this area here I
have got a zoomed in view for additional
clarity here so turning to the
photographs as what is there at present
so these four pillars are going to be
removed the timber gates removed and
then replaced with the detailing as I've
just shown you so as you can see the
character of this over this particular
area and then within the site there is
some debris which is also associated
with construction within the the barn
conversions and that is debris which is
proposed to be utilized as part of the
construction of this new driveway but
also in association with the existing
barn or the barn conversions which are
underway
so this is the site looking from church
lane which is in the corner of wells
Wells born Road and Church Lane so this
is a look at view looking in so kissing
tree house you can see within this area
here it is a long distance view and
there is existing screening but the
dwellings will be with located within
the vicinity currently screened retained
to be screened by the existing tree
planting this is a view looking from
some changes since James's churchyard
looking northeast so kissing tree house
here and the application site behind the
cops of trees and that's the photographs
that I need to show you with respect to
updates there are a number in the report
which you need to take note of there is
an additional verbal updates to report
namely that the current edition of the
village album stone villagers design
statement is a 2015 version not the 2010
it sets out in the report however alpha
sis consider that there's no substantive
changes in relation to this application
with respect to that chairman the
recommendation is to grant Planning
Commission subject to the amended
wording of conditions 11 and 14 as set
out in the update sheets and the
remaining conditions and notes Assessors
and the committee report Thank You
Louise just a second on the update
sheets the second paragraph it says the
planning authority must have regard to a
little a local finance consideration as
far as it is material what does that
mean
that's a reference to their community
infrastructure levy which discounts all
implement as of tomorrow that just
clarifies what wait that has that
particular payment has it is a material
consideration but it's only got the
limited weight in the planning balance
thank you and just one quick one there
will be a move on the area special
protection or something wasn't it Jason
to the actual property is that correct
no the the application site is within
the conservation area Alveston
Conservation Area and there are two
listed building so it does affect the
setting of these two listed buildings
kissing tree house and and st. James's
Church it is identified in the Alveston
the draft neighborhood plan Strafford
neighborhood plan as being within the
alps and villages does not sorry we've
been within the built-up area boundary I
think thank you very much Andy right and
no Paschal town council speakers today
so our first speaker el stickers is Jane
dodge and Richard Hyde if you'd like to
come forward please thank you
thank you have 3 min your own time just
press the button at the bottom when
you're just a on protocol we did send
some slides through to your officers I
just wanted to see what protocol is
about showing those as we speak would
you like to give a prompt when you want
the slide moving on well what I see
there's six of them we also did send a
copy to the counselors in a letter and I
think what's probably better if we keep
this first one up as I speak if there
are any questions the other slides might
help in those questions it I think is
gonna be too complicated to roll through
and give you prompts as if you're happy
with that German yes by all means
in your own time counsellors good
evening we will focus our three minutes
on the conservation aspects of this
application the APA believes that the
key issue is the one that was at the
center of the bomb will man a quart of
pale judgment namely that the greater
the negative impact on the significance
of the heritage assets the greater the
benefits that will be needed to justify
approval even if the harm is less than
substantial it still carries
considerable weight unfortunately the a
VA feels that the report does not
adequately ask this question it doesn't
refers the hugely important Kedleston
Road High Court judgment it uses an out
of date for the desired statement and
has ignored the main arguments and
conclusions of your conservation officer
quoting Kedleston heritage assets are
not just the mayor buildings but they're
complete settings in this case the
Parkland of kissing treehouse and the
graveyard of the church this application
damages the setting for instance evening
light pollution detracting from the
church's spectacular windows or everyday
domestic activity and buildings
introduced into part of the village that
the conservation area document says has
a sense of isolation tranquility and
privacy and if you visited the
churchyard this will be very
to you once the harm is done it can
never be undone it is very unfortunate
that the most recent 2015 village design
statement has not been used this update
gave unequivocal priority to protecting
the hidden nature of the village and
views particular to the self unsupported
by 97% of the village and has been
strongly reference in the inspectors
report for the successful planning
appeal against another development in
this parkland finally I turned some of
the key comments made by your
conservation officer this report is
clear that the rural and parkland
setting is of considerable importance
quoting the report harm to the setting
of a heritage asset is not dependent on
public access or views how the assets
are experienced and they blink view
glutes views will be harmed by
development within this rural part and
setting the conservation officer
conclude and I quote given the loss of
green space development within the
significant open parkland alteration to
the character of how the sub area is
experienced I consider that this
proposal fails to preserve or enhance
the conservation area given this you'd
have thought your planning officer
construes would go into considerable
detail of how the benefits this
application outweighed the harm this has
not happened the analysis presented can
it best only be described as superficial
and must lead a reasoned observer or a
planning Spectre to conclude that they
are significant
so the question we respectfully pose to
you tonight is that you need to be
absolutely certain that you are getting
real and substantial benefits to
compensate for the clear tangible and
unalterable harm to the heritage assets
we think you are not
is that elongation should be refused for
reasons stated and already circulate in
our letter and week I so that they will
underpin a very defensible position if
there is an appeal Thank You chairman
members there any questions you like to
race
it's cutter carriage yes I don't suppose
you can I don't even have much time do
you know anything about b2 and b12 of
the of the strap driving neighborhood
plan in respect to this or indeed the
design statement well I'm glad you asked
me that counselor Carrie because I think
it's quite important point your officer
did refer to to the the the Bou AB and
that it was going and going through that
whole process it's quite interesting
that actually this built-up area
boundary in the latest section 16
consultation from Stratford District
Council stated to the examiner that they
believe that this site should be placed
outside the site of the blue app so I
think it is really quite a significant
point that wasn't my point but it's an
interesting one
Thank You Cass Richard you talked about
the 2015 absinthe Irish design statement
and the report referring to the 13th
world significant differences between 13
and 15 that we need to be aware of in
considering this sorry 10 or 15 pole
dress council Richard I'm going to Hart
hand you over to mrs. Judd who's the
expert and the main difference was that
we'd actually done at a village survey
in 20 in 2012 where we canvassed the
whole village we actually got a 97
percent response which is an incredible
response to a to a survey of a village
it just goes to show how passionate we
are and and the key thing was that the
two amendments that were were discussed
was that keeping the open space was
vitally important to all villages and so
we re emphasize that in the 2015 can I
just pick up a little point about
openness as such like I noticed that
some of the photographs that was shown
the officer there down the road it's
quite well screamed from the road so
which areas are you talking about from
an openness perspective that is shall we
say open to the general public
well show some of the other photographs
I mean I noticed miss Coleman did her
took her photographs I think it was in
September the date on they on the
photographs we took ours more recently
admitted leathers there's not so much
trick and not too much relief coverage
but of course that that's the case for
half of the year isn't it I mean there
so when when you if you look at her
picture number two that's number one the
next one down that's actually a picture
from the churchyard glimpsing through
our photograph is much closer to the
actual vegetation than his Coleman she
was right at the at the other side of
the church'
and you can see quite clearly there
would be two houses right there so you
know they'd be quite visible from the
churchyard when people are visiting
their loved ones in the graves thank you
I can't tell you in feet or meters yes
maybe the officer I mean I can give you
I think we can guess but perhaps the
officers got it an exact figure what
dimension were you asking for councilor
bounds what dimension were you asking
for
it's approximately 30 meters 30 meters
any other questions members no thank you
very much thank you very soon
our next speaker is under Murphy agent
Thank You chairman first is the
principle of development the site is
located within the settlement boundary
of Alveston as defined by the draft
draft upon a van neighborhood plan I'm
hoping at some point there'll be a shot
that are on the screen as a category for
local service village about 32 houses
can be accommodated at Alveston so far
there are only nine built or committed
houses so there is plenty of capacity in
the village
the main issue of concern to local
residents is heritage the site is part
of the garden - kissing tree house and
has been urbanized by development in the
1980s and 90s namely the entrance gates
the tarmac drive ornamental buildings
haha lawns and the pond it is for this
reason of urbanization that the land
falls within the built-up area boundary
as defined by the draft neighbor plan
whereas the agricultural land to the
south of the haha lies outside the
design of the houses is a modern
interpretation of gateway lodges to a
large country house and uses render wood
cladding and aluminium framing the
design is an evolution of the wide range
of architectural styles within the
conservation area and will serve to
raise design standards in the village
and in the district indeed the Alveston
village design statement which I have
taken into account States and I quote it
is important that the gradual evolution
of the village continues and that it
does not stagnate or die the houses
measure only 3.6 meters tall and will be
largely hidden behind the 1.8 meter tall
roadside walls
and mature trees furthermore the houses
will be positioned either side of the
entrance gates
leave leaving open views to fields that
lie beyond the modern haha to the south
there will be a little impact on the
setting of the listed buildings some
james's Church and kissing treehouse a
corridor of inter visibility between the
church and kissing treehouse is retained
and will be reinforced by the
construction of a second haha the
primary access to kissing treehouse from
kissing freeway will be closed
instead access will be from the south
via an existing gate of kissing tree
lane
this creates a pleasing grand entrance
through landscaped gardens to reach the
formal front of the house this is the
route of the original 19th century
private road to kissing treehouse before
the drive was closed in the late 20th
century 30 seconds please reopening the
old drive in this manner will enhance
the setting of kissing treehouse the
many benefits of the proposal are listed
in the conclusion section of the
committee report and include 36,000
pounds in seal so I ask you to support
the officer recommendation and grant
planning permission
thank you very much then was there any
questions you'd like to ask us Richard
and the simply that haha you're not
filling in the existing one you're
creating another one is that right
that's correct here so leveled to
different levels of land Sam I know the
levels of land either side will be the
same there is a cross-section drawing on
one of the plans to illustrate this
there's because the land other side is
the same but there's a diagonal so it
drops down and drop down consumer so
it's not going to be a tiered no all all
the land is the same level thanks Jay
you made some comment about the design
of these two bungalows is somehow unique
is going to haunt the you know the
buildings speck in Alveston I mean maybe
we haven't seen them clear enough
designs but they just looked like
bungalows with with nice cutting on them
I'm not
convinced they stood out to me as
something that was it's it's I'd like to
understand
I like clarification on that point
what's so great about these bungalows
that they're going to revolutionize the
building's future buildings of Alveston
seemed a strange point to me well I
wouldn't say they're revolutionary they
are clearly contemporary design I think
they are unusual designs they are
deliberately flat routes and I know that
a flat roof houses elsewhere in houses
John I think it's helped us to delete
the materials but the way they're
articulated I think is unusual and is
interesting and the materials are render
because the kissing tree house itself is
render so there will be white rims on
part of it and also a large timber
cladding to it
aluminium framing indoors and I find it
interesting I find it unusual
deliberately they are low to the ground
we did pre-application consultation with
offices in order to ensure that they
were set too low to the ground and that
in itself I think is important in terms
of local character I think they are
unusual designs they're not trying to
replicate or mimic historic designs or
local historic vernacular
it's a deliberately modernist design and
also Alveston is split into various
subcategories and having read the
village design statement I'm I'm
perfectly aware of that and kissing tree
way has a wide variety of architectural
styles which is mentioned in the
finished design statements not thickness
I think you've answered the question of
the house of Audrey about the the actual
properties in your your consideration on
castle Orton did you have a question no
any other questions please no okay thank
you very much next speaker is councillor
off
the planning officer told me several
times that her decision to approve this
application was very finely balanced and
that it would be up to the committee to
decide whether it should go for approval
I'm here to demonstrate to you that the
planning officers report lacks balance
firstly the term modern bungalow sat on
grade 2 listed land between two grade 2
listed buildings said in a conservation
heritage landscape to support the
district's five-year housing land supply
casing treeway is an unlit Road lane
with no made up pavements the SDC
planning policy team suggests that this
piece of land should be excluded from
the Burrup and I quote from the
submission of comments to the
neighborhood plan the manor house to the
southern edge of the village and its
entire curtilage should be removed from
the settlement boundary this therefore
demonstrate that this area is a rural
nature with parkland and is not part of
the urban landscape suggested by the
planner please look at the second
paragraph in page 90 of the port where I
believe that the planner is
contradicting herself by agreeing that
this area of land still maintains its
open character I refer you to two of the
comments made by the conservation
officer on page 87 of your report she
states that this development will
however still impact on upon the rural
setting an open character affecting both
the setting of the listed buildings and
the conservation area and further
considers that the proposal to alter the
former historic open agricultural
parkland setting and the isolation of
the Church on the corner of kissing tree
way will cause harm to the heritage
outlets altering the character and
appearance of the site outside of the
lane and how the assets are experienced
and yet the planner has chosen to brush
over these statements by our own
conservation officer the phrase less
than substantial harm is concerning it
still implies that there is harm and you
should consider this carefully historic
England also brings this up in their
report and say that you should identify
that the balancing exercise needs to be
undertaken to see if there is sufficient
public benefits to outweigh the heritage
harmed benefits outweighing harm I refer
to the bottom of page 84 of your report
listing the benefits that a bit flaky
creation of employment this is shortly
at once was there built and would
increase spending power locally and
would be an economic benefit to the
existing shops and services there are no
shops or existing services buses have
not surf Ralston for a very long time as
you can see on the picture before you by
placing two modern bungalows between two
grade 2 listed sites this will create an
urban field and will in turn have a
detrimental impact on kissing treehouse
and the church the detritus from these
dwellings I washing lines and children's
play equipment will spoil the
tranquility of the grave rod of the
church this is a comment made by the
inspector when considering a previous
application of 15 houses on the same
location the light pollution from these
proposal tools also have a huge
detrimental effect on neighboring
properties and the village as a whole
the light from the large glazed windows
will be seen from far away and an unlit
unmade up country lane the primary first
the lane is being urban in character how
can this be the landscape is an
important part of the rural character
christen teahouse and the church it's
not urban in any way let's discuss
design we know it's subjective but for
those of you who attended last week's
planning training on design you'll
remember that it was stated that new
housing should have a sense of belonging
and fit in within the surrounding area
do these flat roof bungalows fit in with
the surrounding area I suggest not they
will have a detrimental effect on the
street scene and will have no sense of
place or belonging to the grade 2 listed
setting it sits within there are better
places to cut housing within hours
Alveston built a very abound rhe in fact
since this application came in a long
time ago six additional dwellings have
been approved in a more sustainable
location in this one in fact it adds up
to 15 now yes we did argue against the
two houses further away but at least
there are not in a grade 2 listed
setting and are shielded by hedging
which these two bungalows are not the
requirements of development in a
conservation area as to prover preserve
or enhance this proposal does neither I
hope you I have demonstrated that is not
finely balanced but as many planning
reasons to infuse let us not find
ourselves with too much now to keep in
building nestled between two listed
buildings and ruining the beautiful
beautiful open landscape forever you can
never go back
this application must be refused for the
following planning reasons it's 30
seconds please counselor the other
person had longer fails the fundamental
requirement of developed in a
conservation area the adverse impacts of
this development significantly in
demonstrably outweigh the benefits and
as a result of the application does not
preserve or enhance the character or
appearance of the artist in conservation
area sdz own Planning Department
recommends to the neighborhood planning
sandwich ruling out hitting tree house
and grounds out to the BU a B fails the
bomb well and Kedleston test that
although the harm to the 300 girls is
less now please views affected by light
permit pollution in appropriate designs
a subset of village in breach of the
2015 BDS village state adopted thank you
hey counselor q tell us more about the
other of the mix of the housing and
their styles of housing within August
and the immediate setting obviously I've
seen kissing tree house from what I can
see on there there's generally white
clad buildings with pitched roofs I mean
is their their own pieces of land via a
kissing tree tree way if this is a proof
will have been will have increased by a
hundred and fifty percent of housing on
a rural unlit unmade Road can't resist
them the style of the proposed dwellings
or just simply no no building enough
location both because it is I mean you
can see the effect it will have on
kissing tree way it's the setting it's
the fact that it's a conservation area
its heritage land it's been there for
years the house was owned by JB
Priestley I could go
I think the one thing I just like today
you said from kissing Tree Lane okay I
do appreciate that the foliage drops off
in in the winter but that looked a very
heavily for pledged area with with
mature trees as well yes if you looked
from the proposed access to these
bungalows you will actually say instead
of parkland and kissing tree house in
the distance your see two bungalows
either side of the gate okay thank you
out of character with the street scene
okay Castle jaws did you have yeah there
you go you'll see a bungalow behind that
car so am I right in understanding that
the 2015 village design statement it
specifically referred to the fact that
the villagers thought the preservation
of the open space between the church or
kissing treehouse is desirable it is and
it's a very important part of the aspect
of the village yes yeah
cattle bones yes you went to the agenda
what the conservation architect said but
historic England appears to sort of say
there is little effect design page you
may be ready but in regard them they
consider the development will have a
little event but they also say that you
should identify the balancing exercise
that need of the needs to be undertaken
to see if there's sufficient public
benefits being employment of
construction short lived and and use of
the local shops and services there
aren't to me it doesn't it doesn't that
does not outweigh the harm that by
putting these two bunkers they won't
have simply doesn't any other questions
of councillor off thank you very
consoling
I shall open up for technical questions
any technical questions with caliban's
whether he is or isn't within the
boundary whose trap for District Council
in terms of the Stratford neighbourhood
plan that's currently at examination
being assessed by the inspector it is in
the built-up area boundaries are
submitted Thank You counselor thank you
thank you I do appreciate your time I
thank you very much indeed
okay so question counselor Richards I
will ask a question then my question is
have Stratford district counsel objected
to its inclusion in the Bill to bury
boundary the Stratford policy team did
make comment to the inspector to suggest
that it be removed from it however the
Stratford neighbourhood plan put it
forward as being included officers
myself as an officer have assessed the
character of that specific area of land
and in my opinion I feel that it is more
using the term urban and its appearance
then the rest of the litter on the land
to the parkland which is very different
in character and I will just clarify
that the 15 dwellings that have been
referred to as in a previous application
were not in this site it with a land to
the south of this site within the
parkland just to clarify that thank you
any other technical questions okay thank
you I shall open up a break the council
carriage
now you won't because I really like
these bungalows I think they're lovely
I might be persuaded to to say yes go
for it I love this design there's a lot
of very nice modern design in our system
in fact it's probably got the most
lovely modern architecture in the whole
district per number however this isn't
the place for them I think
we've got cs9
we've got cs5 we've got CS 8 which were
mentioned in the report we've got the
alga stand village design statement the
comments from our conservation officer
and I think heritage England or
something all stating that there's less
than significant harm we need to find a
reason to weigh against that and and I
think the reasons given don't satisfy me
enough so I would recommend that we
refuse this application council Richards
council Jones cazador well first of all
I'm gonna ask cancer the cancer Kari if
that's a proposal it is a formal
proposal so I need to understand your
reasoning its first I I disagree with
you that I would certainly I know that
my board residents would argue that
where they live has a better ecliptic
mix but that's for another day I think I
also I disagree that these are great
designs I think they're awful and I
would not want to see those be developed
in a place like obstinate Italy in a
conservation area so if you can
articulate your reasons for refusal just
so I understand them I'm inclined to
second your while you're doing that
council Giles well I can assist with the
reasons for refusal which is that the
conservation officer is very clear that
this hat is harmful to the grade 2
listed setting and in my mind that's
obvious the the beauty of this setting
clearly in that open space now just
because you don't have a building which
literally blocks the view between the
two buildings attention if you are
standing at kissing tree house looking
at the church or vice versa clearly your
eye is going to be drawn to those two
bungalows of modern design but putting
the design to one side two urban
structures the whole point of that is
you've got this this stretch of land
which sits in contrast to the parkland
that's one of the things that is
important about it will suddenly you cut
that in half and you have that
uninterrupted view so I understand that
that's tried to be mitigated by bringing
the height down but for me that's of
limited relevance because it's about
where the eye is drawn and you've
diminished the size of that that
openness it's highly significant that
that's been something that's recognized
in the Alveston design statement it's
clear to me that there is harm so we
have to look at what are the possible
public benefits now what we've got is
the addition of two houses in terms of
our land supply we currently have a good
buoyant a five-year housing land supply
I do not see any benefit actually I
don't see the benefit of the addition of
two houses particularly as being
significant given the state we're
currently and I don't I certainly think
the other benefits are extremely
negligible so I think the clear reason
is that the benefits do not outweigh the
clearly identified harm to the listed
buildings I'm setting mmm I actually
know this area quite well I've actually
been to functions at kissing tree house
and far be it for me to be our wedding
events and wedding venues but I should
got married at the church and I've
always felt that kissing tree house and
its woodland that surrounds it is
actually the heart of the world
character Alveston and I have to say I
would struggle to think there was
anything that did harm to that I think
would be a major a major shame really
would would not want to see that
Casavant yes I'm always very suspicious
when the conservation now okay that puts
a page in a full application I think
it's one of those
well if you read it it's he should have
said well I don't like it but they
didn't so it's one of those things that
the planners have got 5050 and as far as
I'm concerned I will go along with the
rest of the speakers okay thank you can
cutter
I think the elements we're talking about
here are harm to the list of buildings I
think that's that's relevant not in
keeping with the area and sense of place
I get councillor Ross point on that one
let me dig go through that training
session not quite convinced because of
course there is an eclectic mix there
but it does reduce the openness of the
area as well and I agree with counsel
Jawas it detracts from the openness of
the views in that area
County character you had a proposal have
you got the reasons for refusing her yes
what they're the same as modest and the
same as yours on page 87 at the
conservation officers comments which
come under cs8 so the last three bullet
points I guess under two dwellings where
it identifies will impact upon the war
setting an open character affecting both
the setting of the listed buildings and
conservation area I think that pretty
much says it all actually but the next
bullet point continues considers that
the proposed a door to the forum a
historic open yes the open agricultural
park and well it says there in the
bullet both the church on the corner of
kissing tree well will cause harm to the
heritage assets so everything that the
conservation officer says I think we
agree with under cs8 move to page 92
under landscape impact and the first
paragraph talks about cs9 where we're
talking about improving the quality of
the public ray realm and enhancing the
sense of place and we come back to
counselor Vaudrey there this doesn't do
that then the next paragraph II
cs5 landscape and natural environment
proposal should minimize and mitigate
impact on the character of the landscape
and regard to local distinctiveness and
this doesn't do that and then the final
paragraph paragraph 3 the Alveston
village design statement identifies that
the open spaces were miscible add
they're surrounding the entrances the
boundaries of the village we carry on
our vicitms concealed setting in
addition as the last sentence the view
across the park land from the junction
of the b4 age six and Church Lane is
identified as an important view in the
Alveston conservation area view I think
that's that would include this in within
it there may well be other things in the
Alveston design statement which aren't
in the report so I think there's plenty
rare to be going on with and let's just
know there's no benefit to weigh against
it really in my mind do you want to have
that one in as well yep point okay can I
just come back for clarification
purposes it seems to me that there are
two separate reasons refusal one
relating to heritage assets and the
development of this this site in terms
of how it affects the neighboring mr.
buildings conservation area etc and the
second one because of the design of this
particular scheme I'm reading that right
from well I hadn't mentioned that it's
now I would I certainly wouldn't mention
the design this specific scene it's it's
the setting of the buildings
intrinsically where it is the view of
the conservation area from kissing tree
lane
yeah you can home if you I don't think I
need any help I'm very happy with what I
said I think I think can I just pick up
on this one I think we're all agreed
with the impact on heritage openness I
think that's one things you mentioned
the conservation conservation area and
the nature of of that particular Lane
yeah which is mentioned I think in the
other some village design statement
that's three weeks however I'm picking
up now a little bit of a conflict
between the two elements for design one
is for one is against including that
within one of the reasons I'm just a
little concerned that we don't if we're
not happy about that it leaves it out
and if we got enough I wouldn't include
it personally I wouldn't I wouldn't
include it but your proposal is proposed
included yeah not to not to include not
to include anything about the design of
the thank you okay I'm happy to do that
myself but I have got any others I want
to include it but I would like to
include it as well I'll withdraw my my
proposal I will make a proposal which is
exactly the same as councilor carriages
but but including the cs9 design
distinctiveness and if I can second okay
with that clarified then if I can just
summarize for them because the buzzer
did without the design far as I'm
concerned it's 30 yards like Church
yong-chol happy to support the last
proposal but I did feel that design is a
personal thing
some would love it or not so I would not
want design put in the reason for review
but currently it is I think the point is
saying that we hate the design so not
it's about whether that design is in
keeping given the setting of our stand
in the other building so it's not about
whether or not you
particular it should it fits in with
that area I think this is the concern
that I do have the proposal includes the
design but is it in conflict with the
area and that's the question okay so can
you just okay right I've got reason one
is effectively a heritage base reason in
the opinion of the local planning
authority the development of this site
would result in less than substantial
harm that's the harm found by the
conservation officer so the character
and appearance of the Alveston
conservation area and the setting of the
adjacent james church great to listed by
reason of in fact sorry my mistake it
should also have kissing treehouse in
there where did we get to by reason to
the introduction of a form of
development that would erode the former
historic open agricultural parkland
setting and the isolation of some
James's church which had caused harm to
these heritage assets altering the
character and appearance of this side of
the lane and how these assets have
experienced the resulting impact is
considered to result in substantial harm
that should be less than substantially
less than substantial harm to the
designated heritage assets that would
not be outweighed by the public benefits
of the proposal the development is
therefore contrary to say two policies
cs8 that's the heritage policy of the
core strategy Alveston village design
statement 2015 and the MPP f so that's
your heritage reason your design reason
is effectively going to the proposed
design and form of the scheme fails to
integrate with the pattern or grain of
the surrounding village and surrounding
landscape in particular views and I
picked up this from the B 408 six is
that the only view that we want to
specify and now that was that was I
think that's irrelevant to that to this
bit if you're talking about is this
about the design of the buildings design
so that's got nothing to do with it
okay would that be more appropriate in
the heritage reason then the view across
the parkland I believe so yes okay
yep so just to clarify that view from
the be 486 forms part of the heritage
reason the first reason and then just to
finish off on that second reason
remember the design reason this would
therefore cause harm which is contrary
to policy cs9 design of the Stratford
elated open district core strategy and
cs5 landscape and also Alveston village
design statement 2015 thank you I have a
proposed account of already you said you
so happy to second that and with those
Commission's members we have a proposal
in a second the vote play for Nia is to
refuse planning permission for 1701
three to 9/4 all those in favor
two against I think you're fine two
against and obtain so this committee
therefore resolved to refused permission
for 17/1 three two - - at all thank you
right our final item on the agenda are
just a couple of minutes for people to
move around
chairman yes good I could I just make a
point of order I'm a little bit unhappy
about attending the next ice on you it
is on my website it could be
misconstrued now I'm happy the council
law counselor Wharton a lot Lloyds Bank
your client yeah I'm happy with that
council law
thank you everybody can we get on with
our last icon the agenda please the last
item on the agenda is 17 such a 308 8/4
and over to you thank you Jeff
so this application is for the change of
use of a financial and professional
services building to a hot food takeaway
so that's a two to a five the
application cited denoted by the black
dots is located within the village
center Studley and just shown here on
the location plans the application also
includes the provision of a ventilation
system and also a shopfront as part of
the design so this shows the the shop
front as proposed and this shows the
ventilation system here done in the
bottom corner so this is the internal
layout of the of the ground floor and
the first floor which is going to be
used predominantly for stuff facilities
for toilets and WC and then a storage
facility also it's just the current
photo the front elevation buildings
currently vacant this is the view just
looking to the left of the of the
Studley of ulster Road and that's the
view looking to the right and to the
rear this is the building in which the
ventilation system will sit and from the
other side of it as well just in there
there's no verbal updates and the
recommendation is to approve subject to
the committee conditions outlined within
the committee report thank you thank you
our first speaker is councillor Beeman
just for a change
Thank You Jay I thought when I got voted
off I'd spend far less time use you to
spend more time here than do anywhere
else thank you um president I wouldn't
use the word president when we're
talking about planning however I think
what we have to look at is consistency
not that long ago we sat here with a
less than 100
away from this and committee gave a
support and objected to that application
almost identical application it was
turning a commercial premises into a hot
food takeaway as we said at the time
there is 17 take aways and cafes within
the village it's moving towards a
nighttime economy rather than a daytime
economy we have a shopper set up next
door and that is financial services so
there is a move for this sort of
business to come back into the village
what we don't want to see is takeaways
where it's actually spoils for everybody
else
the mix of shopping in the villages is
identified in there in the parish plan
is well below what we'd expect that's
picked up in the offices report we think
that this could be used for something
other than a takeaway there are other
problems with making to take away there
is no public parking for this so anybody
that parks will be either in the bus
stop isn't it running across the road or
in the shorts today aren't in the lay-by
it mentions car parking in the coop but
the coop is restricted to coop customers
it is not open to village to be free
putting a shop in something car feel
quite strong about it is for their their
customers so he's going to encourage
people blocking the labor or parking in
the for Draft opposite or on the W lines
in marble only there is a similar
premises in Redditch less than four and
a half miles wide that just deliveries
and deliver so suddenly so we don't
understand why another pizza place is
coming into the village there is 150
yards to the right of this one and there
was one at the top and High Street
already so there is already sufficient
provision of that type of food
parameters within the village it's not
offering anything different and we just
think that it is a real poor use of what
is a valuable building right in the
heart of the village we just that you
refuse this
I think error Ward member has put some
very valid reasons for ifyou've refusal
in his comments and I don't think I need
to reiterate them so we would have
actually refuses application thank you
sir okay very quickly what was in that
building how long has it been empty it
was Lloyds Bank until twelve months ago
Lloyds shut it was the last Bank in the
village if ever we won't need have
commercial premises office premises this
is no ideal sort of building forward
there is parking for staff on the back
but not for customers so it is very much
geared towards financial services or
sort or service industry will be an
ideal premises for that we use and just
so I'm clear what's either side you've
got ice is the ICS is the financial
services and what's on the right hand
side it's a hairdressers to the other
side and the to the first floor on both
those buildings are both domestic
accommodation as well so the extractors
will cause problems for those because it
is domestic accommodation this flats on
the side
Thank You counsel thank you our next
speaker is ocean Robert I hope I
pronounced that correctly thank you
thank you have three minutes in your
time Thank You Gerry I did I do not wish
to add too much to the officer's report
it is very comprehensive and which we
fully support there one or two points
were selected withdraw members attention
to as it stands the unit contributes
nothing to the local economy and
distracts from the character and
appearance of the village whilst there
is concern about this being another take
away in the centre we are keen to
distinguish ourselves from the
traditional takeaway and highlight the
number of significant benefits that
would result in terms of job creation
the report before he states that unit
will bring around 20 new to new jobs
this is an average it is expected that
this particular unit will create around
30 jobs and these modern of these more
than 90 percent are due to be local
employees the wages of which were
therefore be spent in other stores in
the centre this is therefore not a
traditional takeaway use that would only
contribute maybe a handful of jobs to
the local economy terms of the character
and appearance of a center the unit has
laid empty since August 2016
in this time the unit has contributed
nothing positive to the vitality and
viability of the center the changes
proposed to the shop front would
materially enhance the appearance of the
unit by opening it out to the street one
of the main criticisms of takeaway uses
is the inactive frontages they create
during the day Domino's different
differs significantly from this norm the
proposal the pros use will operate from
11:00 a.m. until 8:00 at night and
provide seating for customers meaning
that the frontage will be active
throughout the day that's attracting
people to the center to the benefit of
both new and existing businesses
furthermore Domino's encourage their
operations to be part of their local
communities through contributions to
local events and charities the store in
nearby redditch has already been able to
assist local charities including a
donation towards Redditch East aspiring
community hub and the owners have
specifically asked to get more involved
in this group they have also made
personal contributions including one to
a lady who is undertaking a midwifery
elective in him in Africa the company
has a community and charity focus which
the local community instead they could
make full use of accordingly we feel
that the proposals would bring
significant benefits to the center and
that would bring if it can be unit back
into beneficial use it would enhance the
vitality and viability of a center while
retaining and strengthening the range of
services services and uses will bring
around 30 new jobs to the area and it
would open up the frontage to create
activity during the day and evening it
is also worth noting that there are no
technical objections in respect of noise
odor and highway safety consequently we
believe that when looking at the overall
planning balance the Dominos proposed
investment and development in steadily
is very much in line with local and
national policies thank you this one
point has this building being advertised
for a to use
yes it was up for sale I believe it was
sold at auction is my understanding but
yes it has been on the open market for a
range of uses yes I was thinking more
specifically on any to use as opposed to
a five for hot food takeaways that was
the the query has it been sold as a to
use that was a question so you're saying
it was sold as a bank it was then sold
as you say are you saying but it was not
changed during that period no no it was
sold with a lawful use of Class A - as a
financial service trying to get
something on clarity on it is it have
you attempted to lease it or rent it out
as a - or was it solely for the purpose
of Domino's you said yes to a Domino's
Pizza place would you bought
specifically for that so have you
attempted to make it a - and gets a
lesson later a number of local
authorities have policies which require
when change of user considers that they
advertise or do certain maybe 12 months
of marketing before an application will
change of uses submitted as far as I
understand there is no requirement for
us to do that and the policies of of
this council and so no is the answer
that no marketing but it was marketed
when it was sold for that use thank you
very much thank you
Kelcey courage just will change this is
pretentious lovely i like dominos pizzas
my son likes Domino's pizzas I know a
lot of people who like dominos pictures
and everything that was said about
opening up the frontage bringing jobs in
is true and you know that's great but
that there is an empty a5 property in
studly
in fact there's probably no it was one
empty a5 property there's loads of other
a five properties take away properties
instantly I'm sure one or two of them
might be willing to be bought out as
I've said this time as I said last time
for a very similar application one
hundred yards down the road for another
fast food outlet
there's too many it's unbalanced there
was there were many many policy reasons
to refuse this and I've outlined them in
here interestingly this committee turned
down the previous application hundred
yards down the road and that was
appealed and this council has defended
this committee's decision Lent in in
their appeal statement and the there
were two reasons one was CS 22 which I
think does apply to this this situation
as well but definitely
exactly the same reasons CS 23 which is
a reason to in our appeal to refuse the
the other one would would apply directly
to this we shouldn't be saying one thing
one minute and then exactly the same
minute saying saying the opposite I
think I'll stop there Thank You
councillor
are they any questions a castle carriage
no okay thank you technical questions
James are you aware of any sales
attempting to sale sell this building
oh I assume post when it was sold none
have been provided as part the
application may be so much in fact this
isn't being sold by Lloyds Bank it's by
the third party I believe this has been
the de poppies been sold and the
applications coming from a third party
yes I don't believe it's formal is map
the applicants Domino's Pizza so it
appears that Lloyds Bank sold its double
those pizza no I see okay thank you very
much there has been requirement that
there's a period of marketing in the
current class not now required all if I
misunderstood that need for that you're
right in certain situations as part of a
planning application we'd ask for
evidence of marketing
the most obvious one of those being
where there's a complete loss of a
business use that's not the case here
it's just a change for one type of
business to another both of which are
considered appropriate in Studley in the
main hall center I entirely agree
thoughtful and dito comments at out by
councillor courage at page 104 and 105
of the committee reports because I think
it's very clearly as we've debated on my
agrees this is a very similar issue to
one we debated before that I think
granting the change of use has the real
ability to undermine the fine balance
that Studley are trying to see because
it's not just we're not just here to
sort of bluntly consider is there an
economic benefit that's that's a nuanced
consideration it's what type of economic
benefit and and and I think that you
know the detail of the policies and SCS
22 but also those policies specifically
to subtly do indicate that and I think
there's a real chance that actually you
you grant the change of use and you not
only are not getting the type it's not
just about the introduction or the loss
of a potential of this being say a
financial services business is the
impact it has on other types of business
so look at next door do you actually
start to undermine them when you stick
them in a row of takeaways and they
start to think you know what we're not
just not going to go to attract the kind
of custom and and service that we need
so it's not just about about that
particularly building on what that
building does it's what it does to other
building businesses in the area trying
to forge that so I entirely agree
I agree entirely with councillor Charles
I think it's also important I was
involved in previous decision that where
we can be as a committee we should be
consistent and so CS 22 and CS 23 seemed
to apply as much for this as it did in
the previous case I would counsel jars
wish to propose it I'd happily second it
I think the reasons have been our take I
completely agree with both members
reasons have been articulated it's the
viability and
the vitality and viability of the of the
change of the change of use from it is a
two to a five isn't it absolutely still
sounds a we have to be consistent we've
made this decision a hundred yards down
the road actually I think it's as
important here because it's right on the
frontage of the road it's between two
existing businesses that are so far
detached from a fast-food business it
could be detrimental to their their
continued viability and so I think it's
those of the key point rates the
viability for change of use from a to
two
five thank you I must admit I agree it
doesn't support a diverse local economy
that's absolutely correct
I'm also be concerned about the
residents adjacent to this who in the
stands flats I do wonder about the their
amenity because of the fans and the the
extract systems there will be odors
inevitably on that one there will be
noise inevitably on that so those two
areas I'm quite concerned about as well
um right any other crammed thoughts at
the moment right I do have a proposer
okay did by councillor Richards I've got
a reason that would read something on
these lines policy CS 22 economic
development promotes development which
provides for a wide range of business
and commercial activity it is considered
that the change of use of pay to
financial and professional 2a5 offered
take away would severely to track from
the vitality and viability of studless a
growing world center shopping and
service provision contrary to the
requirements of policy CS 22 of the core
strategy unconscious is also CS 23 and I
in my view I think it's probably the
same reason was 22 and 23 in the same
reason for refusal if you're comfortable
would not boss the role of the village
center as a focus of local shops and
services as a separate for CS 23 I don't
I mean frontier doesn't matter if
they're bought of roll into one or not
it's the same stuff so
I'm sorry those and cancel jaws okay and
did counsel vol 3 I'm happy to second a
second thank you so members the vote
before you is to refuse Planning
Commission for 1703 Oh eight-eight such
for all those in favor
thank you this committee therefore
results are refused plane permission of
75038 8/4 there being no more business I
declare this meeting closed thank you